foreign buddy to our our education
committee here this is the first meeting
which we've had of the committee as a
whole here and uh it's our orientation
and so I'd like to just I'm introduce
myself I'm Rick Lyon I chair in the
committee will have a chance to
introduce ourselves in a second but
first of all I want to address the issue
of these these mics here so everybody
knows and is familiar how to use them
when you're using it you have there's a
I assume that's why you put me over here
I have to have my red button on so
everybody yes I apologize
um we're all a little shaky trying to
get back into this again
um I'd like to go around and introduce
ourselves we have two people sitting in
front of us at the tables in the in the
middle we have on my right and in the in
in your your left in the in the audience
we have Senator Ward Senator Ward is the
chairman of Senate Finance Finance
Senate education I'm glad I'm glad she's
working with us on the education policy
side
um and then we also have represent
Edwards here who is also from finance
so there's a there's well over 50
percent of our appropriated budgets
sitting right in his lap a little bit
more than that probably
yeah that's right so so uh folks if we
have to work with uh we work with
division two in finance and they are the
ones that hear all our policy stuff but
then all our bills are taken up again by
the total finance committee uh after
they come out of policy so with that I'd
like to go ahead and
start off because I haven't met a lot of
you we have nine new people on House
Education this year out of the 20. so
that we have a lot of Need for this this
training and development here so let's
start over on my right here and
introduce yourself a little bit of back
your background experiences prior to
life in the legislature
um and we have about 30 minutes to do
this the clocks in the wall are not
moving time is standing still over there
um so by about 10 o'clock we want to be
completed this portion of it and into
our presentations from the Department go
ahead please
so hi um my name is Peggy Balboa I'm a
newly elected representative for
Rockingham 38 serving uh Greenland
Northampton and rye
prior to this I served nine years on The
Rice School Board and a total of 12
Years on the right budget committee
my experience on the school board a lot
of my area of expertise was in
curriculum and instruction as well as
policy development
um I also served on the joint Sao 50
school board for the same nine years
serving as Vice chair for four years I
believe
um my I graduated from Georgetown
University with a Bachelor of Science in
Psychology and I went on to Columbia
teachers teachers College
pardon me
public speaking was a little new to me
so bear with me
and I had my master's degree in special
education
I have four children they all attended
the Rye Public Schools
education is very important to me and
that's the primary reason that I ran so
thank you and I look forward to serving
on this committee
thank you very much representative
Balboni a familiar face not as being in
the legislature but being an
thank you representative Ladd so I am
Kareem cascaden and this is my first
time sitting on this side of the table I
have set many times on the other side I
represent Cross County District 5 which
is a city of Berlin
um I was educated in private public
schools I hold a bachelor's degree in
foreign language a master's in
elementary Ed and a doctorate in
educational leadership
I have taught in private schools and
I've taught in public schools I searched
23 years as a principal in 12 years as a
school superintendent I retired just
last February after serving as a
superintendent 10 years in Berlin one
year as an interim in Littleton and one
year as an interim in line
I have served on the New Hampshire
school funding commission and the New
Hampshire pre-engineering technology
advisory Council and the New Hampshire
teacher Effectiveness task force 2.
currently I assess uh English we call it
an esol English second
English speakers of other languages so I
maintain those licenses and I Mentor
teachers who are getting certified in
that area because they are um
quite a shortage I currently hold a
certification as a superintendent a
principal an elementary educator and an
English speaker of other languages and I
look forward to being able to contribute
hopefully in a positive direction on
this committee thank you thank you very
much representative cascadden go ahead
hi I am representative put your red
button on sorry hi I am representative
Valerie McDonald I graduated from Salem
High School which is the district I
represent Salem Rockingham 25. I'm also
currently a college student and I hope
to provide a contemporary perspective to
the education committee which is what I
campaigned primarily on and to increase
Civic engagement in high schools and
public education thank you thank you
very much represent McDonald
representative I'm representative Katie
paternal I am a representative from the
Carroll County district 6 which is
wolfborough and toughtonborough prior I
have a bachelor's degree in nursing and
I hope never to go back to that however
so I'm running ran for office instead I
am homeschooled my four daughters for 20
years and um was also a representative
on the New Hampshire homeschooling
Coalition and hoped to offer a different
perspective on this committee thank you
thank you very much it's always good to
have somebody from nursing we have
Senator Ward sitting right in front of
you who is also a nurse who's true
thank you representative Cornell
my name is Patty Cornell I represent
Manchester Ward 22 note Manchester
District 22. they changed my district
this year this is my fifth term as a
representative and my fourth term on the
education committee I was a middle
school guidance counselor in Manchester
for 36 years I'm also a Manchester
Library trustee and I'm recently
appointed to the Manchester Water
Commission
and education is what I run on so this
is my thing to do thank you very much
and welcome back
representative Tanner you're down the
corner there I am stuck around the
corner here
um I'm representative Linda Tanner I
represent Sullivan five which is now
Sunapee in Springfield I'm a retired
teacher from Kearsarge Regional High
School 35 years uh teaching health
health occupations physical education
and doing a lot of coaching I also was
an Adjunct professor at Colby Sawyer
College in wellness and I have a
bachelor's degree in Health Ed and a
master's degree from Dartmouth in
liberal studies
I serve on sunapee's school budget
committee and town committee which I
have for a long time and this is my
fifth term on in the house of fourth
term on education pleased to be back
thank you very much representative going
represent luno your next
thanks very much Mr chair uh Dave Luna
from Hopkinton uh representing the
people of Merrimack County District 9
which is Hopkinton and and Bo New
Hampshire and um uh this is my starting
my fifth term I spent my first two terms
on the Commerce Committee and uh the
last two terms um uh here on House
Education term as Vice chair and as
Deputy ranking and um uh my uh basically
you know as far as far as background
goes I went to MIT have a degree in
electoral engineering computer science
started a tech company in the 90s that's
all behind us nowadays and got involved
in in our local school board served on
the Hopkinton board for 12 years I also
serve on advisory boards at MIT UNH and
nhti and by far in Shannon uh uh likes
to hear me say this but the the work I
do in The nhca Advisory Board is is by
far some of the most meaningful that
that I've had in my uh my career for
what it what it does what the
institution does for uh for students uh
back in 2020 it chaired the commission
for school funding that um that Karine
and and Rick and and Mel were uh were on
as well as a number of others and um
look forward to working with everybody
on the committee and and let's have a
successful uh session
thank you very much representative uh we
will be introducing one of uh uh
represent luno's students here has done
an Extended Learning opportunity here uh
but we're going to do that after we have
a go around here and get into some of
our other materials representative
myler's next up representative Meyer is
the ranking
um a representative from the on the
Democratic party here he's also been
previous chair of this committee welcome
back oh thank you uh Mr chairman uh
again my name is Mel Myler I'm like my
colleague here I represent Merrimack
District 9 which is Bowen Hopkinton live
in Kentucky
this is my sixth term on this committee
and I have
been for 57 years I've been a Public
School advocate I've been 21 years I was
the executive director of Nea New
Hampshire
and eight years I directed The Field
operations of the National Education
Association out of Washington DC
I am married for 58 years have two grown
children and four grandchildren which
take up a lot of my time and I'm glad to
be here and I look forward to this
coming year thank you thank you very
much representative representative
corneli is our vice chair of the
committee here representative cordelli
and I thank you Mr chairman Glenn
cordelli I represent Carol seven which
is tough and Borough Wolfeboro and
Ossipee and this is my sixth term in the
house sixth term on the education
committee
um my professional career was in
Information Technology
um and prior to moving to uh New
Hampshire about 14 years ago I served
six years on my local school board which
would have been the third largest in New
Hampshire and then four years on the
local Finance board
thank you very much uh I'm
representative Rick Ladd I come from
Haverhill I've represented Haverhill
Benton Landau Piermont Warren that's a
new District I've been in education all
my life
right when I was born I was learning and
right now it's uh after being a fourth
grade teacher for a number of years over
in
Winthrop Maine uh then went off to
Alaska where I was the school
administrator up there for a number of
years and distinguished National
principal from that state I've been
involved with a member of commissions
here in the state I chair the commission
on public school infrastructure I'm a
trustee with the university system New
Hampshire I am a black bear however I
graduated from Orono and there's that
little that camaraderie so I'm pleased
to be back and this can be a fun
activity if you don't really let it
overwhelm you so
um you just hang in there everybody
we'll make it uh going on to
representative Ford beside me he's
acting as a clerk today representative
Ford it comes with some experience too
in higher education I'll let him explain
that representative Ford
thank you Mr chair yes I was in higher
ed for a very long time I was a
professor assist uh Dean vice president
and president I was also president of
the faculty Union
both Nea and aft I'm rather unusual in
that regard not many people get to go
into Administration who've been in
presidents of unions but as it turned
out it was a good experience all the way
around I have a different if you may
perspective than some of my colleagues
and uh and that's useful in this
committee because this is a committee
that has to deal with all aspects of
education and it helps if you can bring
those perspectives to the table not just
one but many of them
um and I've appreciated the opportunity
to be here this is only my second term
which is probably why I got this job and
uh they they promised that I don't have
to take off my socks the numbers don't
get that big so we're all right but
nonetheless
um it's an interesting committee and
those of you who have had experience
with it know just how busy we are where
it stays I'll use a polite where
vigorous throughout the session no
question
so welcome to the new members buckle up
because here we go thank you very much
representative
good morning thank you Mr chair my name
is Arlene cortiello I am from Atkinson
this is my first term
my uh
educational career began as an academic
reference librarian
I'm also the mother of three uh I sent
them all to Catholic school I'm the
product of a Catholic Education myself I
served on the school board of St Joseph
Regional Catholic School in Salem for
five years
um
I then uh
went back to school to UNH and got a
master's in English literature and I was
an adjunct English instructor at St
Anselm College for about a dozen years
I've recently left that I've returned to
my original career as a librarian and I
am now not as an academic librarian I'm
now a public
library
assistant director of the the library in
so um
my goal in serving on this committee is
to improve education for all students
whether they are uh
public school Catholic school private
school home school
so I am very happy to be on this
committee well thank you welcome
representative
hi I'm Kristen Noble and I represent
Bedford
um my background is in network security
software and I actually stopped working
when my daughter was going to school so
that I could be more available to her
she's 16 now and has told me that it was
time for me to get a job I'm not sure if
she meant a volunteer job but here I am
um I had started a parents group in town
to help them navigate education issues
through covid
um education is very important to all my
constituents in Bedford and I'm very
happy to be serving on this committee
thank you thank you very much
representative Noble maybe you can help
me with my cell phone it's not working
representative Hall
good morning I'm Muriel Hall I'm from I
represent Beau and Hopkinton in District
9.
um I'm a lifelong Granite stator
graduated Groveton high school I know
it's yesterday the Civics High School
class was there and that was kind of fun
meeting up with them I have an
elementary Ed degree from Keene I have a
master's degree from Plymouth I taught
in BO for um 37 years 32 years
um and we've been put 40 years in all in
education
and with an adjunct for Plymouth as well
I started in special ed then I taught
mathematics and then computer technology
I served I was in the I had a special
election last year uh or in 2021
actually
um and so I served on the resources
Recreation and development committee and
then I was moved over to the education
committee and I was thrilled even though
it seemed like it became a full-time job
uh it was the best move ever I married
42 years two sons one in Denver and one
in DC so that's not too handy but I do
have a grandchild my first grandchild so
that's exciting
um and I also like representative Ford I
have a fair amount of union experience
uh I was the Nea with our local
president and and sort of on their
government Relations Board
uh and I like as I said I love working
on this committee uh and a huge child
advocate thank you thank you very much
represent uh any Representatives that
are coming in that are on the finance
committee are welcome to sit up with one
of your bosses right here
um so fellas if you want to come out and
sit at the table here we will have the
finance aspect starting here in about 10
minutes
uh representative
thank you
good morning thank you Mr chair I'm
representative hope Damon I live in
Croydon for 37 years I have Sullivan
District 8 which is the towns of Acworth
Langdon lemster Goshen Washington
Springfield sanpi Corydon and Claremont
a remarkably diverse District in terms
of the schools and many things I'm
really honored to be here my career has
been as a dietitian diabetes educator
and also an eating disorder specialist I
ran my own practice for 37 years I
retired last week
sold my office it's kind of exciting so
this is my new
highly energetic full-time Pursuit I'm a
product of public education I have two
adult daughters who are products in
public education I'm a vigorous
supporter of quality schools
and I will work very hard to support
that
um
I was one of the leaders of the we stand
up for Croydon group that work to
restore our public school budget this
past spring when it was initially cut by
53 on a motion from the floor
at our school meeting we do not have sb2
in Croydon we did restore the school
budget we learned a lot and
I think our story has been heard by most
people in the room
I'm also a board member of New Hampshire
women's Foundation which if you're not
familiar is a Statewide non-profit that
does research education advocacy
philanthropy and Grant making on behalf
of women and girls in New Hampshire
I've been involved with women's
foundation for over a decade and it has
informed my understanding of the needs
of women and girls in New Hampshire in a
very data-driven way and I encourage all
of you to look at our research reports
we do one-on women we alternate a report
on the state that's a women one year it
just came out and state of girls in New
Hampshire of the alternate year
um
I bike the Prouty I love you all to join
me cancer research is important and
research in general basing our decisions
and facts thank you so much thank you
very much representative Damon
representative Damon we have a bill
coming up on Thursday you'd be very
interested in HP 35 dealing with eating
disorders as a matter of fact I read
that and said why did I not know to be a
sponsor of this well represent Ellison
welcome back thank you thank you Mr
chair uh I'm art Ellison I represent
mayor mag district 28 which consists of
Concord Wards one two and three uh this
is my third term uh first two were on
this committee and plowing on forward
with a third one uh
I've worked for the Department of
Education for 38 years
prior to doing this work I coordinated
Dropout prevention programs for the
department and schools around the state
uh also administered a big esol actually
the biggest esol Network in the State uh
came all the money came through us uh I
have a master's degree in teaching
social studies at the high school level
I have a doctorate of adult education uh
both of which seem to have been relevant
to the work that that we are doing and
will be doing so I I'm happy to be back
and I'm primed to get on with this thank
you representative representative
woodcock
good morning Mr chair thank you uh my
name is Steve Woodcock and this is my
third term in the house and third term
on education committee I represent the
town of Conway uh and all the little
colonies around it uh academically I
have a bachelor's degree a master's
degree and a cags all in education
education Administration I spent my uh
buckle my career over 30 years in public
education as a teacher coach a high
school administrator a Dean assistant
Dean and a principal I've been a
principal in three states
I then went on and spent 12 years the
teaching faculty member and department
chair at the college level and coach
and I had the opportunity to meet
Allison several years ago when I started
the first Dropout Academy and the
Kennedy High School District and he was
on the adult ed which is very critical
in helping funding our drop-off
prevention for for youngsters I spent 20
years in the local school board I have
an outstanding ten-year-old
granddaughter and I had the privilege of
being married my wife for over 50 years
thank you thank you very much
representative Wright right is it yep
try try yes thank you Mr chairman I'm
Margaret dry I represent the Sullivan
County district 7 which is a float
District representing Plainfield and
Cornish Newport unity in Charlestown I
live in Plainfield I've been an
emergency medical technician for over 43
years and active on the rescue squad I'm
also a cemetery trustee and it's not
really a conflict of interest and the uh
a vice husband and I have nine children
uh I homeschooled all of them through
High School it took me 30 years my
husband was an original member of the
home education advisory Council and
helped pen the first homeschooling
statutes the state had we've been active
in our community in our interaction with
the state uh secondary schools has been
through the community colleges Plymouth
State University and some online
colleges thank you thank you very much
good morning thank you Mr chair
colleagues and guests my name is Mike
Belcher I'm here representing the good
people of Wakefield and the other towns
in Carroll district four
um my background is perhaps a bit
different I after graduating from
Portsmouth High School went on and spent
a number of years as an EMT and then
paramedic I bounced around various uh
Industries including heavy industry
working in as an electrician and a
painter Blaster and I also spent a
number of years teaching in various
medical programs at colleges and as a
contractor
um
as one of the few people here who has
not had a formal education in education
I hope that I can bring a a helpful
diversity of thought to this committee
thank you thank you very much
unless you like us I've been a teacher
for over 50 years actually ever since my
first brother was born but I started
getting paid as a teacher when I was in
high school when everybody all the other
girls were babysitting I was teaching
clarinet
um
I have my degree in math I started in
physics got my degree in math and
teaching your certification in secondary
math Ed
but I have taught everything from
Bible study to Art maths to Firearms
Highland dance to
multiple instruments I if I know it and
you want to know it I'll happily teach
you and I still love the fact that when
I don't have to be here I can go teach
kids who are being homeschooled
so that's still my passion above
everything else
and oh I rep I'm Hudson I mean I'm
Hillsboro 38 the float for Hudson and
Litchfield
thank you very much representative well
that gets us right around the table here
and we did that just about the time we
were allocated right a little about a
minute after 10 and we're already going
but I'm what I'm going what I want to do
first is take about 30 seconds here if
we would represent luno would you
introduce your your student to us sure
thank you very much Mr chair
um Hal could you uh just sort of
so how is a is our um is actually
um melon my Extended Learning
opportunity student uh he's from
Hopkinton high school and um and I think
this is going to provide just an
incredible learning opportunity for him
and this is his first time at the
witness stand here using the mic and uh
let's uh let's give him give him a shot
Hal if you would introduce yourself
thanks so much for having me this is a
great opportunity and I'm so happy at
you that I'm able to experience it here
with all of you I'm a senior here this
year at Hopkinton high school as
representative Luna said I'm
experiencing an ELO with representative
luno representative Miler and
representative Hall I've always been
interested in politics I'm the vice
president of my class and this year I'm
lucky enough to be a part of the New
Hampshire youth legislative Council
which I think is going to be an amazing
experience once that gets up and running
in the next couple of weeks uh next year
I'm lucky enough to be attending Cornell
University with a major in labor
relations and I'm really really excited
to see what the future holds so thank
you so much for having me thank you very
much and best of luck there on Cornell
on the Finger Lakes yeah okay so so Rick
we'll we'll see how quite a bit over the
uh I I hope we do we'd love to have
students come in it gives us that
perspective that we need to hear
and I want to thank all the people in
the committee here we have a wide
variety of backgrounds and I think we're
ready to move forward here uh sitting in
front of me now we have several chairs
and I've mentioned them before we
representing Ken Weiler representative
Edwards and Senator Ward
any other folks are on finance which
would like to come out and sit at the
tables you're more than welcome to do so
with our other guests right here we're
just about ready to get into the
okay some people are more bashful nuts
because if we if we want to ask
questions and I'm sorry we don't have
the mics there available for you but we
will if you have questions please feel
free to ask questions as we will we're
going to try to hold our questions until
the presentations are done and at this
time I'd like to invite uh Caitlin Davis
from the Department of Education to come
forward and Caitlyn you can bring any
folks that you want to bring along with
you up here that are going to help with
the presentation
thank you good morning I am Caitlin
Davis Caitlin with a c for the record
um on behalf of the entire department of
education I want to say welcome to all
the new members and welcome back to all
of the members that we've worked with
over the years either on these
committees or other committees
the Department of Education is looking
forward to supporting the committee
throughout this legislative session as
we work with the many bills that all of
the Committees in front of us represent
have including many education bills and
the state budget
um I have personally had the pleasure of
participating in these orientation days
for more than a decade now and it's it
gets it every single year we get better
questions it gets more interesting you
guys ask me questions that I don't know
that I have to research
um and we really enjoy this part of our
jobs so it's exciting for us to get to
know each one of you and kind of work
with you and and help explain the work
that we do that we're very passionate
about
the Department of Education has the
responsibility of supporting K-12
education throughout the state and that
includes school districts Public Schools
non-public schools education Freedom
accounts adult education and other
educational opportunities in addition to
these programs we oversee teacher
credentialing and higher education prep
programs Vocational Rehabilitation
Social Security Disability determination
and many other programs
the department is made up of four
divisions the division of learner
support which is directed by division
director Melissa white to division the
division of higher education and higher
education educator support which is
directed by division director Steve
Appleby the division of Workforce
Innovation which does not have a
division director and the division of
Education analytics and resources which
I oversee
today you're going to have the chance to
hear from two of my talented staff Amy
Clark who is the administrator of the
state Bureau of school facilities and
specifically she's going to be speaking
about school building Aid and Mark
meganello who's the administrator of the
Bureau of school Finance so with that
I'm going to pass over the mic to Amy
who's going to start her presentation
thank you thank you
welcome Amy thank you Amy's an engineer
too folks so
you people from MIT and all these other
folks
you got a comrade there uh good morning
uh thank you committee members uh
senators and representatives as well uh
chairman lad thank you for having me uh
I am again my name is Amy Clark and I
can see some of you through the
obstacles here
um and I am the administrator like
Caitlin said of school facilities so
Department of Education is a big place
um but really school facilities almost
everything except for Career and
Technical Education Centers when you
think of those facilities they are under
a separate program but almost everything
else happens under my Bureau
um and part of that today
um is talking about the building aid
program which falls under my Bureau I
have a handout in front of you
um titled building Aid our cute little
logo on the top with a leaf uh and
um it says Bureau of school facilities
on there so if you want to locate that
that's the packet that I'm going to be
going through I also have two other
packets that are just fyis unfortunately
I didn't have enough handouts for the
center folks but
um that I'll just really have there for
information so today for the most part
we're just going through this building
Aid packet and then of course anything
else you want to discuss it's your
meeting so I'm happy to adjust uh for
you all
uh there are uh five pieces to my packet
um when I reference page numbers they
all come from different sources so
there's page numbers on the bottom you
can ignore those page numbers for this
purpose and if we're talking about page
numbers I'll reference them in the top
right corner of the page
um that is all the page numbers for this
whole packet
there are 11 of them I'm mostly just
going to talk about page two so uh if
you want to start there uh this is our
program I am challenged with trying to
put my program on one page and here it
is so this is the if I have to say one
page of building Aid this is the page
you might want to study and everything
else is really this supporting
information
my contact information is up there uh
we're gonna for some of you you've heard
of building Aid and you know you're just
dreaming of your shopping list that's
fine
um
um others it's brand new and I'll talk
to you and your might not understand any
of it and that's fine uh it's a it's a
big program feel free to contact me at
any time if you have any questions uh we
can this is I love to talk about
building AIDS so call me anytime
um the most important thing to you
probably all is where does this fall in
the law the legislation is under RSA
198.15 and supported by Department of
Education roles in Ed 321
and the basics are what is building Aid
building Aid is really just State
dollars for school construction projects
Public School construction projects the
thing about building Aid that's all it
is State funds to help schools uh us
help school districts
um with their school construction
projects
the that portion of
um the state portion in law is between
30 and 60 percent so the grant that the
state gives out if somebody were to
receive one the state portion ranges
from 30 to 60 percent with the local
communities picking up the remainder
um as you can imagine the the rate is
dictated by law and that is
um more you know more affluent
communities getting the 30 percent and
less affluent communities up near the 60
percent one thing I'd like to point out
about that rate it is not a linear rate
the average rate is 38 so
um when you're thinking about what the
average Community gets it's 38 if you're
a 40 community and you're like how come
we're 40 well you're above average
that's I guess I'll just leave it at
that
um
and
um let's see so that's the building Aid
rate that's the abortion the rest is
covered by the local communities and the
source of those funds is the education
trust fund
the funding structure now here's where
we get into some fun the funding
structure from
1946 this program started and ran for 63
years all the way through 2012.
um and on this might shock you but
you're all already sitting the schools
would submit an application we would
tell the legislature how much money we
need you guys might specifically want to
close your ears on this part but then it
was funded so essentially the schools
set told us their need they filled out
an application we reported to the
legislature in the legislature funded
that amount that was requested so
all eligible projects were funded up
through 2012.
well
um actually that's not true but we'll
get to that that was what the funding
structure was at the time all the way
through 2012.
um in 2013 that structure in law changed
in 2013 the state said we can't continue
to fund all of the projects
um we're going to change the law and
we're going to only fund some of them
um and what happened is that they put
there was a moratorium well let's talk
about that in a minute sorry
um that there was a cap on building Aid
that was put in the law of no more than
50 million dollars a year would be spent
at most on building AIDs that was put
into law so now when you don't fund all
the projects you now have to make it a
competitive project so now the law also
include included criteria for schools to
be competitive over that Grant amount
those things could be
um
life safety issues overcrowding Ada
issues
um in appropriate spaces for teaching
whatever curriculum they needed like you
know if you had a high school space that
didn't have the high school science
space that you needed
um those are all points that would allow
you to creep up
um as showing that you needed building
Aid more than another application
what also significantly changed is the
way that
um projects were paid so from 46 to 2012
projects were paid over the life of the
bond and this is important to know how
projects were paid in the past because
it affects right now projects were paid
over the life of the bond so and I'll
get into an example in a minute but then
in 2013 projects were paid differently
if you got an award 80 percent of that
award was given up front which is much
different than getting it over the term
of the bond so you'd get eighty percent
of your award up front you'd finish your
project and you'd get the remaining 20
percent
so let's just take an example let's do
some math right there's some other
people you're it's right engineering so
we're gonna do a quick math example uh
and that example is on your paper
um for if you want to follow along so
the old fundings well let's just say a
school district takes out a 20-year Bond
for a 40 million dollar project so
they're building a new school for 40
million I realize I have to update my
numbers probably but let's just say they
got a good deal now 40 million dollar
School 20-year bond to build a new
school
let's say their state portion between
that 30 and 60 percent let's say they
got they were a 50 community and they
got 50 Aid so of their 40 million dollar
project they're gonna get a 20 million
dollar state aid and then the local
community is going to have to come up
with the other 20 million dollars the
old funding structure would have paid
over their life of the bond that 20-year
Bond so the school would have received
on average one million dollars a year
for 20 years to pay that 20 million
dollar state aid
in 2013 when the law changed that now
meant that that 40 million dollar
project that was receiving 20 million
in-state Aid is still going to receive
20 million in state aid but they're
going to receive 80 up front
16 million dollars they're going to
complete the project in a couple years
and then they're going to get the
remaining four million dollars of that
project so you can see the communities
are receiving that 20 million dollars
within a couple of years time they start
time and finish rather than spread out
over the 20 years
um
that's important when we talk about
um what we call the tail so we'll talk
about that in a minute
um
from there
um that's what the law says so let's
look at the history is in the bottom
here
um in the top greenish
um that's the 63 years between 1946 and
2009 that 63 period uh 63 period
projects were funded and met demand okay
however in 2010
there was a moratorium put in place and
between 2010 and 2019
the state said we're going to put a halt
on building Aid a two-year moratorium
every two years it just kept being
reinstated for 10 years the state did
not build any projects so in 2010 if you
can kind of figure out the timeline and
you know we're paying for all of these
projects in 2010 somebody says we don't
have enough money if you cut if you
think about what 2010 was like that kind
of probably makes sense in 2010 people
said we're going into a moratorium and
kind of reigning in on this spending on
school construction and then while in a
moratorium into 2013 that's when that
law changed and that moratorium
continued with the exception of 2018
there's one exception in there and you
can see I'm now in the gray area that
10-year moratorium there was was one
application
um emergency project that was funded in
2018 the legislature lifted that
moratorium funded that one project and
then closed the moratorium or went back
to the moratorium in 2019 that project
um for those of you interested was
Hinsdale Elementary School they needed a
3.6 million dollar renovation to correct
some significant structural issues uh
and they are a 60 Community they got 2.2
million dollars in Aid
um and
um that project was funded
um
in in the next three lines in that table
are the bienniums so in the moratorium
was lifted in 2020 for the first time
and five you have to apply for building
I8 ahead of time so five school
districts applied for building eight
even though we were in a moratorium five
school districts said hey we kind of
think we might come out of the
moratorium let's just prepare just in
case
um in those five projects uh total cost
for those five projects was 45 million
dollars they were rent one of them was a
renovation one was like a three million
dollar Edition they weren't filled
builds but those were the what the
projects we received their requests from
the state was 17 million that biennium
three of those projects were funded by
the state uh and uh for a total of 8.6
I am going to go back I apologize but I
want to explain what that last column is
um so if you recall
um the old funding was you get money a
little bit of money for 20 years right
if or whatever your bond was I had a
couple of schools take out a 30-year
Bond so they would get whatever that
130th roughly of their state aid we call
that the tail uh well one of the next
Pages talks a little bit more about this
but when you hear the state us talk
about the tail we're talking about this
extra money we keep paying on these old
projects the funding mechanism is
different now So eventually that last
project that we are paying for will
eventually be paid off their bond will
be done in 2041 so in 2041 we won't have
a tail anymore but until we have a tail
we have to still talk about the tail and
so in that column at the very last
column where it says 53 million dollars
per year that's the tail so we are
continuing even during the moratorium
the state paid that obligation to pass
construction projects that 53 million is
the tail it's it it fluctuates it's
that's the average between 29 2010 and
2019 it was you know sometimes it was 60
million sometimes it was 45 but um the
average there is 53
um throughout those years
and then that and then that 2.2 million
dollars is the new project so this last
column represents the tail those
obligated payments fast projects plus
any new projects we funded that biennium
or that year
so now back in the blue now that I've
kind of explained that you can see that
last
um fiscal 2021 row that last column says
40 million dollars per year plus 8.6
million that just represents that the
state appropriated on average 40 million
dollars per year and then they also
funded those three projects for an
additional 8.6 million for that biennium
in 2022 23 schools got
um wind that that building Aid that
moratorium is finally lifted so
applications were due July dates are so
important right applications were due
that biennium July 1st of 2020.
schools had a lot of things on their
plate in July of 2020 you don't put an
application in overnight schools work
very very hard on these applications
they are very detailed you work with an
architect you've got planned preliminary
plans drawn up you have mechanical
engineering facility studies so it's not
something you do overnight schools had
to really put some time and dedication
into applying for building Aid during
the pandemic so early on during the
pandemic too so we did receive
12 applications
uh the Department of Education ranks
those applications based on what the
state law says we funded we got enough
money 30 million dollars was
appropriated for new projects and so we
were able to pick off the top project
and fund them we had some more money
left so of that 30 million we picked the
second project off and was able to fund
those two projects uh with the 30
million dollars that the state granted
us so of 12 projects that put
applications in they were requesting 140
million dollars and we've received from
the state 30 million so it allowed the
state for us to fund two of those
projects
now we had another application process
that opened up
um last uh I guess I'll say last year in
2022 uh July of 2022 17 school districts
applied their projects totaled 564
million dollars their request from the
state is 227 million dollars of course
we don't know what our budget is going
to be so we don't know how many
applications we'll be able to fund
um so that last column just says 26
million dollars for our tail payments
those obligated uh payments to pass
projects plus whatever the state
appropriates for new construction
projects so
there's a lot of information on here and
um if you need to go back to anything
um those are the numbers but I'm also a
visual graphics person so if you want to
go to page three
uh uh let's not go to page well that's
short we'll go we'll go to three page
three not much of a graphic but page
three
um if you're wondering what your rate is
in your community here's a list of those
rates uh if you were a Cooperative
School District that weight is just
rated weighted by the number of students
you have from each of these communities
but there are the rates right there
um it's also continues on page four
and those rates are recalculated every
um every year those applications are
open we do that in the fall
um the year school districts are
applying and it is uh function those
rates are a function of two criteria
median family income
and equalize valuation per pupil and
what's important to remember I think
about the rate is it is a rank in the
state so some people say oh median
family income isn't really accurate
um that may or may not be true but is it
accurate in the sense of ranking
um do you does each Community kind of
still rank in that same order so the
formula puts everybody in a rank from
median family income equalized valuation
per pupil and their ranks are averaged
so that's how that formula is derived in
the law
and then page five
um this um
this is a graphic of the tale so I'm on
this page here
um this is what people say is the tail
it I guess that I didn't name it but I
can see it I guess I can see the tail
and you can see it hey it's getting
smaller and smaller and smaller and
that's because we don't fun projects
this way anymore that every year we pay
off a few every year I've got somebody
that's finishing up a 20-year Bond and
those projects are falling off the list
we went into a moratorium in 2009 but we
didn't start making a payment on a
couple one of those projects until 2011
they had a 30-year Bond so that's why
this goes out to 2041 if anybody kind of
wanted to be like why did we change the
law and we're still paying projects in
2041. 30 your bonds exist school
districts coupled school districts to
pull them out but for the most part you
can see a big jump in 2030
um it tails off so
um that's the dark the dark color is
officially the tail
obligated uh payments to past projects
and historically the legislature has
always funded those projects even during
the moratorium
the lighter blue
um bar or the bar on top of the darker
blue one is in 2010 remember that's when
we went into a moratorium so budget was
really really tight the state
um right or wrong the state took out a
bond themselves to pay the obligated
payments to school districts so the
states Bond I always get a couple
Chuckles from you on that about that
decision
um for a Visa card just just so that you
know in law that practice is now
prohibited
um in law clearly states the state
cannot do that but the state did decide
to do that in 2010 so we are having to
make bond payments
um every year
um it was a
20-year Bond so you can see in 2030 that
payment is done we make our last payment
in 2030 on that state bond that was used
to make those obligated payments in
2010.
now the dotted lines at the top that go
like this I personally think it's
important to notice that they're jumping
up and down a little are the new
projects so in 2020 in 2021 that
biennium that was the 8.6 million
dollars that's on the chart 6.7 in the
first year of the biennium 1.9 in the
second year biennium those are for new
projects
um in 2022 and 2023 of course we're in
2023 uh now
um
those um for the first year the biennium
um 30 million dollars was appropriated
for new projects and zero million for
year two of the biennium
now if you remember the in 2013 the law
capped building Aid at 50 million
dollars per year which is why this chart
only goes up to 50 million so that chart
goes up to 50 million because the law
says you can't fund any more than 50
million however in 2022 you see all of
that well they did fund more than 50
million I've got my past payments to
past projects I got my bond payment plus
30 million dollars for new projects what
the state did just for last year is they
in House Bill 2 they lifted that
cap just for that one year to allow that
30 million dollars and then none was
appropriated in 2023 so you can kind of
see it's
um it basically took some money in year
two and put it in year one is um sort of
what that what that was
now we're in 2020 well we'll be talking
about 2024 and 2025 you'll have lots of
bills about building Aid
um and that dotted line is a TBD so
um
in the table you'll just see the numbers
that derive that so just walking you
through the table real quick the fiscal
year is there if you want to know what
the actual tale is for each year
um for 2024 that tail payment obligated
payments to unpass projects is 20.6
million my bond our bond payment to on
that 2010 bond is a 6.8 million that
total I've been calling it Debt Service
but that total debt is Our obligation is
27.4 million
the next column it says 50 million less
Debt Service the reason why I calculate
this number is because schools often ask
if building Aid is fully funded that
means they're want to know how much is
available if that 50 million dollars is
appropriated that would be 22.6 million
dollars in 2024. if 50 million is
appropriated the Department of Education
will have 22.6 million dollars to spend
on new projects
um in 2025 you could read those numbers
across but to me the take home message
to schools is that I would have 26.1
million dollars to Grant out for new
construction projects those two numbers
we are are we rank projects in a
biennium list
um so what we really want to know is how
much money we'll have in the biennium to
fund new projects so the last column is
just 48.6 million dollars so for so when
schools say if building Aid is fully
funded next biennium how much money are
going to be available for new projects I
say 48.6 million dollars if the
legislature fully funds building Aid to
what the law says right now
um
so a lot on that graph too
um so now I'm going to keep going and
then you can
tons of questions because these next few
pages are very quick you Page Six
seven and eight are the 17 projects that
applied for building aid for the next
biennium fiscal 24 and 25 these schools
are ready for a construction project
well there's a little asterisk by that
um they haven't necessarily received
voter approval they were prepared to
submit an application to see if they
could get state aid to then see if they
would be moving forward with voter
approval some schools seek voter
approval ahead of time a little easier
in the cities to do that than the others
without knowing how much grant money is
available
um but this is the list of 17 schools
that applied they are in order of rank
so we received the department the
Department of Education receive those
applications last summer we spent time
ranking those applications we present
them a preliminary list to the school
building authority in
December then the school building
authority verifies our ranking checks to
see if the Department of Education
um asks us questions about our ranking
followed the process then submits that
over to the State Board of Education
with State Board of Education also
verifies that information and publishes
this list this is the approved list by
the State Board of Education it was
approved in December uh November 10th
for the in order of rank for
construction projects
so what this means is if we get any
funds for new projects we're going to go
to rank one project and we're going to
offer them
all of the money that they need to
complete their project we do not prorate
this this isn't like everybody gets a
little bit it's
um number one school there is Rochester
they're they're proposing to close those
two schools consolidate and bring a new
Elementary School to Rochester
um try not to talk about all projects
specifically but they're current
buildings are from the late 1800s and so
um uh they sit very nicely at the top of
this list they are proposing
um to build a 33 million dollar School
Rochester is a 60 community so their
State Building Aid request is 20 million
dollars 20.1 so if 21 point million
dollars Elise is granted to the state
for a new state for new projects they'll
be the ones to get get that money first
we just keep running down the list until
we run out of money
um some people are probably already
asking if building Aid were fully funded
we would get 48.7 million dollars how
many projects are would be funded and
the answer is three the top three
projects almost would be funded um the
last one would be shorted I think a tiny
bit but for the most part all three of
those top three projects will be funded
however
um these these projects still need to go
to their voters for approval so this is
still the local local they still have to
go to that local process and say hey
we're going to receive this money if so
are we ready to build this project if
they say no then we just work down the
list
um so
um you know if I don't want to use
anybody for an example I hate to use
them if School X fails their vote then
we're just going to go to the next
school on that list and work out until
we don't have any money left
um that's so that's some for you all and
ten and eleven those are the obligated
payments on past projects so all of
these school projects were built prior
to
um 2000 that was built during the war or
prior to the moratorium applied prior to
the moratorium
and those projects are still receiving
State Building Aid
um because they were were paying on the
life of their bond so you'll see some
projects in there you'll see their
payment years
to take the top project Amherst had a
renovation project to Mount Vernon
School
their school
um their amount eligible for cost was
5.6 that million that we paid 30 percent
on so their Total Building Aid was 1.7
million and we're paying 2010 to 2029
they're receiving 53 593
000 from us uh no that's how much they
have left I'm sorry their payments for
fiscal 24 and fiscal 25 are listed there
and then the remaining payments
um if you're curious how much
um those remaining payments are there's
a total column on the bottom in fiscal
24.
um that is that that's that tail 20.5
million and then 17.2 million which
you'll see on that graph as well
so I think
I did decently trying to fly through
that
um I'm more than happy to thank you very
much Amy I do have one question in
looking at that list for 24 uh Rochester
Colebrook Monadnock
um and that then we're out of money if
we allocate or appropriate what we're
supposed to appropriate
um Colebrook has closed the academy and
the tuition their CTE students across
the river to Vermont Canaan
is there any how do you deal with the
issue that you may have a high school
that there's also they're requesting
School building aid but they also may
have CTE that they're moving into that
building is that going to come out of
another fund of money like the the
Career Tech you know I just I know where
it comes from but I'm it's a question we
may have asked from folks here yeah
that's a very good question so the
building Aid law allows building Aid to
be applied to CTE spaces so those
projects that project a lot of that is
CTE space for that building Aid project
what they can't do is they can't receive
um you could get CTE funding that would
have paid for 75 of your if you got a
CTE fund fun funded project it would
have paid 75 percent and then that
remaining 25 we would have paid building
Aid on so that though that practice that
law was changed in 2013 I think maybe
even earlier
but the law still allows any approved
program space to be paid for with
building Aid so those CTE spaces are
eligible for building Aid thank you are
there questions from the committee
representative Myler
thank you Mr chair the question on the
the rank order list that you have here
is this does that get ranked every year
or like for example if you pay for the
first three does that mean that conquer
then comes up to the number one the
coming year or how does houses what's
the status of this list on an annual
basis
um very good question so we this list is
a biennium list
um it's for fiscal 24 and 25.
um you know I always tell schools we'll
we if we're lucky we'll get two buckets
of money for new projects
um you know whatever that those payments
are let's just say first it's 25 million
in year one and 25 million in year two
we'll offer that to the top rank project
we'll we'll offer it in rank order until
we run out of money
um then year two we finished paying off
whoever we couldn't fully pay and then
we continue to that on the list so then
it's closed out the school tools that
don't receive funding would move up and
stay on the list in the next biennium
only if they're approved at the local at
their District's legislative body so it
would be difficult for it's I don't know
what I don't know what these districts
will do and I don't but
I I think it's difficult if you are down
on the list to go to your voters and say
hey we're not going to get any money but
would you approve our project so that we
can stay on the list
um
it may happen
um but maybe for the top schools they
might they're only going to stay on the
list next biennium if their District
legislative body has approved the
project
we do have legislation coming before us
that's going to take us right through
the whole process policy process for for
this issue uh looking at the timeline
look for application through the time
that the award is awarded also we're
looking at the issue of do they
automatically stay on that list if
there's another communities coming in
with a higher priority in terms of need
uh surpass that these are all issues and
questions which we have to have some
resolution on and there is a bill there
are three of them coming to us that
we're going to have to resolve here
uh if I look I'm on page five of your
um if I read this right we have about
41.3 million dollars worth of tail left
from a 2010 bond that we took out the
light blue portion of that photoed all
that sounds that sounds right yeah and
then as I look at the darker blue that
looks like it could be about 111 plus
seven million dollars and then those
those obligations are done from those
long-term and going forward if I
understand information right we will
never see a tail again because we find
correct by by funding these kind of
obligations is there is there penalty
for funding in advance
um I do I say at least if most of these
schools I think are working with the
municipal Bond Bank and you can't pay
those off early from what I've heard
from the municipal Bond Bank
um that they can't have a you know a
20-year Bond and in year 15 just finish
paying it that they're they're stuck
with that Bond
thank you
see you might be noted that back in 2009
2010 there are those in the room right
now that remember Our obligation was 540
million dollars
we've been whittling that down
represent Weiler did you have a question
you had your hand up I just wanted me
correction the reason why I get it
moratorium
during those years that you show us
paying off all the things we were
constantly growing and enrollment
began to realize from 2009 the
enrollment is shrinking and it's headed
down so we went to a moratorium before
that all or something we were building
new schools to adapt to new students
after we got to declining enrollments we
said why do we need the kids building
was here so we went on the moratorium
for those 10 years
oh well that makes sense
right representative Cascade and you
have a question yes thank you
representative Vlad my question is
um Korean technical Ed had a funding
source where centers were on a rotation
to be eligible for those funds if they
were ready for renovation what not and I
heard you just mentioned that briefly
um does that funding still exist or is
building a the only means now to
renovate whether it's CTE or regular
buildings that funding program still
exists they're still on a rotating they
still are in a rotating basis and is
that funded about the same every year or
is that different
um I I don't know I don't know much
about the CTE we skipped it last couple
a year or two back uh the we're at the
end of that rotational about the 28
schools or so centers that is an issue
which has to be resolved are we going to
start that again so in another so many
years another 20 years you might get
some money to rebuild your CT which is
now an antique right so that is a huge
problem which we're dealing with here in
the state
this area of funding and we will have
the Career Tech and people here later on
the 17th that's one of the areas that we
were looking at with Jeff beard how are
we going to perpetuate how we're going
to move forward with this uh particular
issue of funding these centers you see
Salem you see some of those areas which
are brand new Bedford brand new but you
have some that just totally outdated
right now and all right okay thank you
we got a problem grab San luno thank you
Mr chair
um and and thanks um Miss Clark for
joining us this morning I was wondering
if um I'm sort of referring to page um
10 of of 11 and um and the the sheet and
I'm looking at
which one am I looking at well looking
at all of the um the the projects that
are still being paid there seems to be
about 120 of them or so and about five
of them I think are um our 2013 or more
recent and uh just picking on one of
them on page 10 and it's um man it's
about I don't know 10 or 12 down
Manchester
um Highland golfs
renovation which was a 2014 project and
um and I'm wondering why it's slated as
2014 to 2032 when I thought it was an 80
20.
um
type of payment plan as opposed to a
that
the Challenger line there so I'm sorry
I'm um
so that Highland golfs renovation uh
2014 to 2032 is there
um Bond payments
um that's their bond payments well
that's their State's contribution to the
district
that's the States I'm sorry that's the
state's contribution but that term that
those payment years are their term that
they that we are making payments on that
project it does I'd have to pull the
project to see why that's not a solid
why why it didn't get extinguished over
say two years or three years you know
from the the 80 up front oh these are
all um this this whole section is these
are obligated payments these were these
are not paid in that new format these
are all
um page
9 10 and 11. yeah this is a list of the
tail payments
So when you say 80 20 that's the new
structure since 2013.
since oh okay I see your question now so
um in all of these projects were applied
prior to 2013. these are all projects
that applied in 2009 or earlier okay
there was some I'd have to pull the
project why there was a delay in payment
it could have been that they went from
maybe there was two bonds one was five
years and this is the remaining of the
now or maybe the head wait for a boat or
something yeah yeah so so these are all
the 20-year payment projects
the term of the bond the term bond yes
okay yeah all right thanks or and it
wasn't always the term of the bond there
are different funding structures where
some are a little different than that
but yes great great thanks I'm going to
interject just for a second Caitlyn uh
how much time are you going to work we
got to get into the other side of this
presentation we have about 45 minutes
left for Matt uh on school fine the
funding formula the adequacy funding
formula are there any other questions
for Amy here this is going to be
represent Edwards and then represent
Belcher
question is given that we have some
consensus revenues at this point if we
were to go ahead and pay off the scale
early
um assuming that that could be worked
out with the bonds would would that
accrue any benefits
I understand this tale would be the
state component of what we owe
um and even if we prepaid our share the
obligation would remain
my mistake and this is for someone
um I'm not sure Mark do you have
I'm just not sure with the um how that
would work
I am
there may be an interest ing
if particularly if we can do it one
legally and two if it could be done in a
way in which occurs to the benefit of
the local property tax
so the real question then gets to be if
we can do it
would does that even help the local
property tax of Affairs because they're
yeah I the the way to help local talk
property taxpayers is look at what
they're paying as an expense so if
they're paying off Bond payments and pay
off those ex those Bond payments that
would help local property taxpayers can
limit their liability but yeah
mechanically how to do that I'm not sure
and the the but you are right like I
think also what you're asking is you
know this is this is their state share
so if you want to kind of figure out
what their local share is
um you know if it's a 30 Community they
have 70 remaining that they'd still be
paying not that it wouldn't be helpful I
think any state any District receiving
that my takeaway is if the state pays
it's an obligated share early
that does not prove any direct benefit
to the local park
I don't
I don't know if there's a way around it
I don't but I have been told
um from the municipal Bond Bank that
they can't that they'll have to continue
to make those payments on their bonds um
they can't
um refinance they can't do anything
different with those municipal bonds so
they still continue to do that but how
maybe there's other mechanisms I just
don't know
that's one of the reasons why we went
with the 80 up front
um and I should mention that as well
I'll just reiterate that because I've
heard from districts that that the new
funding structure of paying 80 up front
and not only 80 up front but 20 upon
completion gives the districts and the
towns a relief from paying all the
interests um off
um that as well that's tremendous
savings represent Belcher and then we're
going to switch over to Caitlin after
you thank you Mr chair I'll keep this
brief
um referencing on page six the
hierarchicalistic of projects by need
I'm I'm just curious for example uh
number one here Rochester uh in section
c it documents due to building physical
security safety and deficiencies now I
would assume that there is uh that there
is much more comprehensive documentation
on those things and how would we go
about getting all that if we wanted to
um
um some of the security information is
marked confidential but for the most
part
um you can the full applications and
you're right there the applications are
hundreds and hundreds of pages so
um that is all in my office
electronically so if you had any
questions happy to help you out with
that
um thank you we will be discussing that
issue uh when we look at the public
school infrastructure fund and much of
the discussion in the allocating those
grants out we had a total of about 28.5
million dollars several years ago we had
3.3 million dollars which wasn't used in
that fund it was matched with some
gopher money so now this year we have
about 13.3
and that's all done in closed session
with Homeland Security and the
department meeting over there and we
just finished a meeting
a couple months ago and we will have
another one coming up shortly here uh so
but uh we will have a presentation on
the 17th touching into this
thank you very much Amy I'm just gonna
well Caitlyn's bringing her a mark up
here I'm just gonna say you have two
other handouts you will hear about these
programs throughout the year for me but
there is a lease Aid handout that is if
you don't own your building this is
basically Charter Schools a lease aid
program to pay for a portion of their
lease and then
um the safe grant that you are
mentioning a lot of that detailed
information about security grants
um just remember the building Aid is not
the same thing when you hear about the
public school infrastructure fund Public
School infrastructure fund is mostly
about security funding security projects
same with the safe Grant
um them and building Aid is about school
construction so great thank you very
much Amy
we would look forward to working with
welcome mark
hello everyone for the record my name is
Mark Manganiello I am the administrator
of the office of school Finance with the
Department of Education you should all
have a handout that says School Finance
presentation and anyone in the audience
I have some extra copies uh on the first
chair there
so School Finance is a big before Marcos
everybody should know that Mark came
from LBA
and so he's pretty much on top of this
stuff are my training from the
legislature and I was really grateful
for the legislature to train me and now
I'm happy to be with the executive
branch but also still support all of you
the school funding is it's a big topic
to cover it's a big topic to cover in 45
minutes there's a lot of people in this
room who have been studying it for years
decades
um there's still interesting questions
that come up that stump us there's
changes in law there are changes in data
so as you're learning this stuff don't
be discouraged if you struggle to
understand it some of it is not
intuitive some of it is complex but just
keep trying and keeps working through
the the information and work with the
department and work with your colleagues
to understand this issue as you study
school funding
so if you go to page two
you'll see a state summary of Revenue
and expenditures
I always start with this document
whenever I do a school Finance training
because it shows you the full scope of
really the economy of our district
public school system and so if you look
at the top
the top bold number there you'll see in
22 fiscal year 22 our public school
districts received 3.6 billion dollars
in funding and so just put that number
in context the New Hampshire economy is
north of 80 billion so our district
Public Schools represent about four
percent of the New Hampshire economy so
that's that's a little fun fact that I
like to share but the reason why I start
with this document is because a lot of
people want to know how their schools
are funded and so this is a Statewide a
summary in aggregate but if you look at
that Top Line you'll see local taxation
so this is your local education property
taxes so the typical taxpayer pays for
property taxes uh they pay a municipal
tax a county tax those have nothing to
do with schools and then they pay a
local education tax which is a local tax
and then they pay something called the
swept which is a Statewide education
property tax so those last two deal with
funding our schools with property taxes
but if you look at this Top Line local
taxation that is dealing with the local
education property tax so that is one
tax out of the four type of taxes a
typical property taxpayer pays and so as
you kind of look at that line
um uh you can go from fiscal year 20 to
fiscal year 21 to fiscal year 22 you'll
see usually on average over the past
three years local taxation local
property taxes have made up 60 percent
of the funding mix of our Public Schools
so you can conclude most of our schools
are funded by local education property
taxes so that's the biggest Revenue
source for our schools
um going further down the second biggest
Revenue source is adequacy adequacy Aid
so adequacy education Aid um it's it's
fluctuated a little bit but between 27
to 28 percent has represented the
funding mix of our district public
schools and the adequacy formula is our
state funding formula there's some other
state sources there you can see hover
around two percent
um throughout the past three years and
so the third biggest funding source for
our schools is federal funding and so
this one has
um as you know we've had a lot of fund
Federal funding coming to our schools
we've had three covid related stimulus
bills uh they're called cares act
Carissa and ARP they all have acronyms
and those acronyms within those acronyms
are more acronyms there's esser-1 sr2
sr3 those are federal funding uh bills
that gave Appropriations funding to our
District's Public
our district schools and uh
um and I believe Charter Schools as well
I'm drawing a blank on yeah Charter
Schools as well uh I I don't run Federal
programming so I'm drawing a blank on
that one sorry
um but what what's interesting to see is
if you look at 2020 that's before a lot
of those Federal bills came into play
um some of them were passed right as
covet hit at the tail end of fiscal year
2020. so you'll see Federal funding um
made up about 4.8 percent of the funding
mix of our district Public Schools but
it's grown now to 8.9 percent and that's
because those Federal funding bills sr1
sr2 sr3 represented 650 million dollars
in potential allocations uh to our
districts and the districts need to draw
down those Federal revenues so they're
going to be drawing down those Federal
revenues over the next four years
um in totality when we look at all the
the whole op all of the funding bills
so you'll see now Federal funding is up
to 323 million in fiscal year 22.
talked about local taxation as the
biggest funding source but on to page
three the second biggest funding source
is State funding
so State funding is around a billion
dollars it's it's north of a billion
dollars usually around 1.1 billion
dollars each year and so these are all
the different state funding programs
that go to our schools
so there's special education Aid that's
for high cost special education students
I'm not going to go into all these but
some of the ones we've talked about
there's building Aid in there but the
largest one the largest percentage of
State funding that goes to schools is
adequacy so adequacy represents around
90 percent of the funding that goes to
our district Public Schools so out of
that 1.1 billion dollars adequacy
um for fiscal year 23 is 970 million so
it's uh the substantial share of State
funding that goes to our school and
that's why it's important to understand
the adequacy formula since it's uh such
a big portion of State funding to
schools
um the other thing I'll point out is
these programs um for some of the people
um who've been on maybe looking at
school funding for a while it's always
important to remember that some of these
programs like building Aid were funded
by the general fund but now those are
highlighted gray back in fiscal year 18
and fiscal year 19 but moving forward
now almost all of these programs are
funded by the education trust fund so
most of all adequacies funded by the
education trust fund and now building
Aid Public School infrastructure
infrastructure fund all these programs
are except for Charter um uh charting
Charter building lease Aid all these
programs are being drawn down by the
education trust fund and not
the general fund so moving on to page
four
you'll see a pie graph
of the education trust fund
and so one of the questions I always get
asked is I thought lottery funded our
schools
um and I thought they funded all of it
um and I'll go they we are very grateful
that the lottery provides their uh their
profits over to the education trust fund
they make up 12 of the education trust
fund Revenue
um so they brought in and this is fiscal
year 22 from the recently published
kafir they brought in 146 million
dollars so uh the Lottery Commission
does does do a good chunk of the
education trust fund but they do not
fully fund the education trust fund the
education trust fund for the fiscal year
closed 22 is uh 1.2 billion dollars and
so those that have been around for a
while they might remember when the
education trust fund couldn't have
didn't have enough Revenue to fund
adequacy didn't have enough Revenue to
fund the programming it was intended to
fund and so it would need a transfer
from the general fund but um
historically the education the New
Hampshire economy in New Hampshire
Revenue has been doing good lately
bringing in Surplus after surplus so
fiscal year 22 is no different we have a
surplus in the education trust fund of
108 million so um
just to get you an idea of the education
trust fund the money coming in it's 1.2
billion currently we're going to end the
year fiscal year 22 with a surplus of
108 million
when you look at the money that comes
into the education trust fund I pointed
out Lottery it's 12 percent
um the the biggest contributor is
something called swept swept is a little
complicated it's the Statewide education
property tax it trips people up a little
bit but when we're talking about those
four taxes that you pay one of them is
swept and how we come up with this
weptus in statute a number is set a
number of 363 million is set and we need
to raise as a state 363 million through
the Statewide education property tax and
the way we do that is we go okay we need
to raise 363 million and we apply it
against all non-utility property
property taxpayers in the state and so
when you take 363 million dollars and
you apply it against a tax base of 250 C
257 billion property values you get a
tax rate of a dollar an equalized tax
rate effectively of a dollar and 44
cents per 1000
so every taxpayer is paying us for every
non-utility taxpayer is paying a swept
tax that money is going
um it's being financially recorded by
the state as coming into the state but
it doesn't actually come into the state
and I'm going to dive into that a little
bit deeper it's complicated and and
people it creates some headaches for
people and I'll go into it when we talk
about the formula and how it flows
through our financials but from an
accounting perspective the swept does
come into the state's coffers not
literally but as far as a journal entry
in our in our books so when you pay your
swept tax we at the state are recording
that is coming into the education trust
fund and so that money comes into the
education trust fund for fiscal year 22.
it was 363 million so that represented
29 of the revenue coming into the
this is the adequacy formula so this
represents in fiscal year uh fiscal year
23 970 million dollars
um in funding for district Public
Schools this is the funding formula for
district Public Schools
and so the way the adequacy formula
Works
um it is first we have to know where the
students live and what what is what
municipality uh ultimately taxpayers are
living a municipality what municipality
is responsible for paying for that
child's education so any child that is
the responsibility of a district public
school system to have their education
funded is counted towards adequacy and
so the way we do that is we look at
where that student is living and we
calculate something called the average
daily membership we're looking at a full
school year and we're seeing where was
that student
um uh being educated essentially or
being responsible for being educated so
um some of you have live in districts uh
you have school districts in community
that don't have schools but if the Stu
the student is in your District you are
responsible for educating them and
that's where adequacy goes goes to the
community that is responsible for paying
for that student that is an important
distinction to make egg
but the way we calculate adequacy is
we'll look at say we have a student
living in Concord attending this Concord
school system and the Concord school
system has a 180 day calendar school
calendar year and they're in Concord for
90 days so basically they're in Concord
for half the time 90 days out of 180
days so we would say that is that one
student has actually 0.5 of a student or
0.5 of an average daily membership for
Concord but now say that student left
the state then there are another State's
responsibility they're not our state any
responsibility so Concord would get 0.5
but say that student went from Concord
for 90 days and say they went to Dover
for the other 90 days so we have 180 Day
School calendar year 90 days in Concord
Concord gets 0.5 of a student Dover gets
the other 0.5 of a student so in
totality it's one student but we track
the student where they are being
educated
districts provide us that information
and that's how we calculate adequacy so
we have fractions of students that were
calculate adequacy to
so when we measure what a student is
and we know where the student lives we
start calculating adequacy and so when
we do one full student so say that
student State and conquered the full
year we would go okay that's one student
that was in Concord the full year their
base adequacy Aid amount when we're
doing the funding formula is
3866.18 this is for fiscal year 24. in
the last two fiscals years uh it was
3786 dollars so we had a CPI adjustment
that occurs every two years so this is
the latest funding formula for 24. it's
now up to
3866 dollars for each student and so
we'll look at that student and we'll go
okay this school is entitled to
3866.18 for educating that student but
then we're going to look at more
additional demographic information from
that about that student if that student
is experiencing poverty meaning they are
fnr eligible they are free and reduced
price meal eligible which means they are
within 185 percent of the federal
poverty guidelines they are eligible for
the their their school lunch program
it's a poverty metric as well as a
program that's being implemented by
schools if they are f r eligible then in
addition to that 3
866.18 we also provide
1933 dollars
and eight cents for that student then we
keep looking at that student and see if
there's any more demographic information
that we can determine about that student
if they have an IEP and are receiving
sped services in addition to the
3866.18 and in addition to if they
happen to be experiencing poverty we
would be paying an additional two
thousand and seventy nine dollars and
eighty nine cents uh that if they're
sped uh uh receiving sped Services the
next metric is English language learner
ell so if they are an English language
learner uh and receiving those services
um in addition to the base adequacy
potentially in addition to f r adequacy
potentially in addition to sped adequacy
um and then lastly the last one's a
little complicated
um if the student is not fnr eligible
not sped up not receiving sped services
not an English language learner and
they're in third grade and they scored
below proficient on the third grade
reading test
um then we pay
756.43 for that student so that's not a
lot of students relatively speaking
because it's a very unique measurement
so we're doing all these we're doing all
these calculating all these grants for
each student and we're tallying up all
the students so you have more than one
student in your school district we're
telling this up for hundreds and
thousands of students within your school
district and we're trying to come up
with an uh a metric and that metric is
once we tally up all these
um base adequacy AIDS and what we call
differential Aid which is f and R and
sped we're coming up with a something
called the cost of an adequate education
and so we call this sometimes called
this constitutional adequacy this is
what the state has determined we need to
fund our schools at in order to provide
an adequate education we need to tally
up all these students and all these
demographic information metrics and we
need to come up with what is the cost of
an adequate education uh based on those
metrics that's under state law
so if we tallied up all those metrics
and we determined that your your
community's cost of inadequate education
was a million dollars then we have to
make sure you have a million dollars in
funding so you can provide an adequate
education
but before we do that before we just
give your community a million dollars
what we do is we look to see what your
community raised through the swept the
Statewide education property tax so for
fiscal year um uh the fiscal year that
just happened or the tax rate that just
went out uh
uh it's a dollar forty four per thousand
so we'll look at how much did that tax
tax levy bring in for your community and
so say your cost of an adequate
education is a million dollars we owe
you a million dollars but say that swept
tax levy brings in 500 000 then we know
that that's that swept tax levy is going
to go to your school district it's
collected by your local tax collector
and they cut a check to your school
district so now your school district has
the swept Revenue that was brought in by
the taxpayers and so if the cost of
inadequate education is a million
dollars the swept brought in five
hundred thousand dollars for your school
then the state needs to cut you a check
for five hundred thousand dollars so you
have the 500 000 in swept and the five
hundred dollars uh 500 000 in adequacy
to get you to the one million dollars
that we are obligated to pay you so
that's how way that's how most districts
work most districts they're swept is
less than their cost of an adequate
education
um where it can get a little tricky uh
or
um uh or this is not most of the towns
most of the towns followed that thing
um is
sometimes a swept is greater than your
cost of an adequate education and so
what in that scenario is your cost of an
adequate education is a million dollars
but your swept tax levy is 1.5 million
dollars we as the state have decided
determined that you have at a minimum
that one million dollars you needed to
provide a cost of an adequate education
so you're going to get the full 1.5
million that was raised by your
taxpayers it's going to go to your
school district so you'll have a grant
of at least a million dollars you'll
have a grant of 1.5 million dollars the
state will not cut you a check under the
scenario because you have 1.5 million
coming from your taxpayers that is
collected locally stays locally and
never actually comes to the state
um and so for uh some of the veterans
have heard this 10 years ago there was
something a concept called donor towns
and so that when people say donor towns
that doesn't exist anymore under the
school funding formula so what used to
happen is if your cost of an adequate
education was a million dollars and your
swept was 1.5 million the state would
take 500 000 and bring it into the
education trust fund and so
um uh communities would call that a
donation and they would call themselves
donor towns
um so that law changed 10 years ago so
that doesn't occur so any money you
raise through your sweat is 100
maintained locally none of it goes to
the state so there's no such thing as
Dumber towns but sometimes you'll hear
uh the expression dollar Town
um sometimes it's used correctly
sometimes it's not used correctly
um but just something to to further
study and understand
um if you if you keep hearing that term
or you want to learn more about that
term
so that's the sort of normal adequacy
formula we call that constitutional
adequacy but the formula is not done
um there's three additional grants that
communities are potentially eligible for
one of those grants is relief Aid which
was enacted in fiscal year 22. and the
way that Grant works is it's based on
your fnr percentage so the poverty
percentage in your community and if your
poverty percentage is greater than 12
percent then you are eligible for a
hundred and fifty dollars per each f r
student in your community and that way
that Grant works is it's on a sliding
scale basis so it reaches a maximum of
if your community is 48 f r 48 poverty
or greater you receive 600 for each fnr
student and so
um it scales up so the more higher the
poverty the higher the grant uh up until
you hit 48 and that Grant is pro-rated
so the state does not spend more or less
than 17.5 million the state will spend
exactly 17.5 million so we adjust the
numbers to make sure the state only
spends exactly 17.5 million
um in that uh existed it started in
fiscal year 22 in existing current law
on perpetuity extraordinary needs Grant
is a new grant that was enacted in
fiscal year 23. the way that brand works
is it looks at both um poverty metrics
and property value metrics so uh first
it calculates your equalized valuation
per F per fnr student and the way that's
calculated is we look at your property
tax base
on an equalized basis and we divide it
by the number of f r students in your
community
and that gets us a metric and so if you
have low property values or high f r
students the number is going to be lower
because the numerator is property values
the denominator is f and R students so
if you have a lot of f r students that's
going to make the the number lower and
if you have low property value that's
going to make the number lower so if
your F equalized valuation over F and R
is one million dollars then you receive
a grant of 650 for each fnr student
um if your equalized valuation is
greater than 6 million uh equalized
valuation per F in our student is
greater than 6 million then you receive
zero dollars in this grant
um and that works also on a sliding
scale basis so depending on where your
equalized valuation per up in our
student lands you get anywhere between
zero dollars to six hundred and fifty
dollars for each equalized value uh each
fnr student and um something with that
Grant and it requires an accountability
plan so in order to complete that uh in
order to receive that Grant you uh the
school district doesn't need to complete
an accountability plan and um tell uh
tell the public how they plan to uh use
those funds to improve student outcomes
and student growth
that's the extraordinary needs Grant and
that exists in the current funding
um the stabilization Grant the
stabilization Grant
um is 158 million dollars uh
approximately and the way you get a
stabilization Grant is there were
changes to the school funding formula
uh that went in effect in 2012. they
went in effect in 2012 in some
communities the changes to the funding
formula
um resulted in them losing uh receiving
less money than they did in fiscal year
2011. and so what the legislature
decided to do was they would hold them
harmless in any funding you received in
2011 you would not receive any less
funding in 2012. and so in order to hold
all those uh communities harmless it
cost back in 2012 it cost 158 million
dollars so that is a stabilization Grant
it's it's it's kind of Frozen in time
and it's based on if you what was the
stabilization Grant in 2012 and if your
community received one so some
communities don't receive a
stabilization Grant because they were
not held harmless in 2012 when there was
changes to the formula some communities
did
and that is when you tally those all up
you get the adequacy formula so it's
cost of inadequate Education Plus those
additional grants equals the adequacy
funding formula and so I don't know
usually uh I stopped for questions here
but
I'll keep I'll keep going representative
if that's is there anybody right now
that has uh an a question regarding what
Mark has just gone through everything
from face adequacy to differentiated Aid
to the grants that are done the bottom
part here accountability and all that
represent cordelli thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mark
could you just touch on uh the second
year of this biennium there was a cut in
the swept from 363 million to 262
million could you uh just briefly talk
about that cut and the impact yes so
swept is normally set in statute at 363
million but there was a language in hb2
for the 2223 budget that temporarily
made the swept not 363 million but made
it 263 million and there was also
language there was a swept hold harmless
Grant uh in hb2 and so a lot of people
when they heard that swept was being cut
they didn't know what that meant they
thought they know that swept goes from
their local taxpayers to their schools
so they thought it was a school funding
cup but it was not a school funding cut
it was a property tax cut and the way
that works mechanically the way it works
with the adequacy formula
um I can kind of be sometimes difficult
to understand and but I'll walk you
through a scenario if your cost of an
adequate education is a million dollars
and your swept is normally five hundred
thousand dollars then the state normally
Cuts you a check of 500 000 but if your
cost of an adequate education is a
million dollars
and your swept now is not five hundred
thousand dollars let's say it drops down
to make the math easy two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars now the state
cuts you a check of seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars so when you
reduce swept for most communities
automatically the adequacy formula will
require the state to pick up the slack
essentially and fund your schools to
make up the difference so what that
means at the end of the day is if the
state's picking up the tab and the
property taxpayers are paying less then
it's a property tax cut for swept
taxpayers so that's how it works there
was also a feature in that uh changes in
hp2 one-time changes in hb2 by the way
this goes into a this is only exists in
fiscal year 23
um did not exist in 22 does not exist in
current launder 24.
um there was also a feature in there
that if your swept was if your costume
inadequate education was a million your
swept was let's say 1.5 million normally
you would get 1.5 million
um from your sweat property taxpayers
but if we come the swept down to let's
say for that Community 1.2 1.25 million
you would receive uh 250 000 less
funding to your uh uh to your school
district so um that would be um uh
considered not a property tax cut uh
your local taxpayers would have to make
it up holding all things else equal so
what the hp2 also had was a swept
reduction hold harmless Grant which
required the state to pay 250 000 to
bring that Community back up to the 1.5
million what they would have received
normally
thank you very much
um any why don't you keep going and
finish this up and then we can have some
questions at the end so so on on page
six is an adequacy history
uh adequacy is a long history uh
I won't go through all this but you can
um if starting on page 20
um it might be uh interesting to look at
um
the only additional Aid component oh
sorry not page 20 Page Six line twenty
uh page six line twenty shows you the
history of the additional additional Aid
components of the adequacy formula so
line 20 shows you stabilization so back
in fiscal year 2015 the only real um uh
besides the I won't go too much into the
weeds there but stabilization was the
primary uh additional Aid component of
the formula
and if you follow it you can see that
there was a reduction in stabilization
it was uh supposed to uh phase out over
25 years under uh uh under law but that
law was uh amended to bring
stabilization back up to the full amount
um so brought up to approximately back
up to that 158 Million number
um and then if you look at fiscal year
21 fiscal year 22 fiscal year 23 24. a
lot of these new components of the
formula the formula has been changing a
lot each year so it's a lot to keep
track of this document just shows you
that the formula has been changing
pretty much every year and so it um if
you want to know those changes you can
use this document to sort of study the
so I just got some informational Pages
at the end there's two informational uh
documents at the end one of them I think
is kind of neat I don't know if um some
of you some of you that pay property
taxes you might go to you might get your
property tax bill and you might go to
the dra website and you might want to
see how your your community compares to
your uh your peers your fellow
communities
um and that's a decent methodology to
compare your tax rate with your uh your
neighbors your neighboring towns but um
this is a document that the Department
of Education published publishes and
what it does is on the far right columns
it does something called uh what I would
call is an equalized tax rate and so
when you're comparing tax rates between
communities you you make a lot of
assumptions and we can get into the
weeds of all the different variables
that could impact the tax rate but one
of those assumptions you make when you
compare your tax rate to another
community's tax rate is you assume that
Community has the same assessing
practices and that is not true each
Community has their own assessing
approach and methodology and so
something this Department of Revenue
Administration does is they tried to
take all property values and bring them
up to a market value and that's the
equalization process so um if you're if
you're one of the people that like to
look at your tax rate and compare it to
your neighbors
um I I suggest looking at this report
because this at the far right column
there it doesn't equalize tax rate so it
Compares tax rates between communities
assuming that they have uh it tries to
uh control for different assessing
practices so it's just a new a neat way
a neat way to compare your tax rate to
your peers
um and you can you can have fun if
you're if a policy walk in that area you
can have fun digging into that the other
informational thing I added
um
every year the department receives
financial data and we process it we're
still in the process of uh this is on
page 16.
um we're still in the process of
processing some of the financial data
we've received from the districts we
hope to publish today a lot of our uh
annual reports that people uh tend to
tend to like and are popular one of them
being cost per pupil
um so this is fiscal year 21
um fiscal year 22 is going to be
published probably today uh we're still
doing some quality control work on it
um
so cost per people uh a metric that
people like to look at um all it is is
it's current expenditures over students
so um sometimes you use cost per people
as a measure of efficiency is
essentially how many research resources
do you allocate per student so some
communities um I'll allocate a lot of
resources per student
using this metric some communities don't
allocate a lot of resources on a per
student basis so it's just a
standardized way to kind of compare your
school district to your peers
um uh looking at kind of that efficiency
measurement
and so that's just an informational
piece that you can look at
is that material come from the doe 25
form your cost per pupil and if so
um how do you discern the difference
between between District a and District
B over here or town A and B when B is
got all the extra things expenses thrown
into it which are not adequate oriented
so the costs like they're spending all
this but it may be for the football team
so we don't we uh the department has
something called the doe 25 it's a
financial report that districts submit
to us it has a lot of data on it it has
2500 cells but it does not have that
granular data um it does have some it
does have some granular data but it
can't really get to what representative
Vlad is is um asking um a lot of it's
rolled up so uh we do have some
financial information that we've
provided to you
um it's it's meant to summarize and roll
up the doe 25 is important in setting
taxes
um and it's important in doing
analytical work but um we do not have
the information that that you're looking
at and we're just looking at current
expenditures over pupils and we're not
parsing out different programmatic
pieces within that school district
thank you Mark
yes representative
thank you very much Mr chair and thanks
uh thanks Mark for joining us this
morning
um on
um on Page Six
uh I I am referencing
um uh row 13. I'm sorry not row 13. row
seven I was wondering if you could talk
about where those students when those
students counts were uh were taken and
how they apply to uh to calculating
um the adequacy Grant in the um in those
years yes that's a good question and I I
don't think I mentioned that
um adequacy we spend uh the school year
we use to calculate the adequacy Grant
in any given fiscal year the student
data is always one year behind that is
different than charter school program
that is different than the EFA program
so um when you look at those metrics uh
hopefully I'm doing it right yes when
you look at that um hopefully I line
them up correctly uh yeah so though if
we look at uh fiscal year 21
um that 167 000 adms on line seven of
that document that represents school
year 2020. and so a a something that's
going on that impacts school funding is
we have declining enrollments
the enrollments generally decline at
about one percent ish a year that's
pretty normal um we can attribute you
know you can hypothesize that that's
attributed to demographic information
people are having less kids so therefore
there are less kids in the system school
system but during the pandemic we saw a
really sharp decrease in student
enrollment it was actually a four
percent decrease in student enrollment
so a lot more than the one percent
decline we typically see and so right
now looking at the student data the ADM
Trends
um
we're kind of back to normal as far as
the one percent decline in student
enrollments each year
um but that four percent we we kind of
hypothesized when there was a four
percent decrease in enrollment we
thought more students might jump back
um we didn't know how many I think some
of them did some of them temporarily
went home school this is a theory I
don't have uh uh as a hypothesis some of
them did go into home education
um some of them did return back did
return back to their District We Believe
but I'm not not at the not as of three
percent so there wasn't a huge jump back
in student enrollment at this number so
um yes student enrollment is one percent
uh uh uh one year behind when
calculating adequacy and as you can see
there we have some declining enrollment
that impacts the funding formula because
the funding formula is driven by student
council represent Damon
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mark
I just wanted to ask about the cost per
pupil does it in any way acknowledge
what
um
What proportion of the people's or
special ed students and the different
costs for them
I think it does not
and we have a bill in on that I I got a
question for you in terms of where we
were last year uh with representative
umberger uh when we're looking at f r as
a de-identifier for poverty uh and now
we've also been considering Medicaid
direct
using that do you have any kind of an
estimate or a guesstimate as far as if
we used Medicaid as an indicator of
poverty would we be receiving X number
of dollars in addition in revenue from
the feds or or where are we on that oh
so if uh we um I didn't mention this in
the in the presentation one of the ways
to determine poverty is for a student to
complete an application and make
themselves eligible for the fnr program
and access free and reduced price meals
within their school another way to
become eligible under current law and
under current practices is they if they
sign up for the TANF program uh uh these
are Medica uh DHHS programs like Tana
snap if they sign up for some of those
DHHS entitlement programs they and they
hit the property metrics as defined by
the f r program we automatically make
them fnr eligible and we count them as a
poor a student experiencing poverty NRF
and our accounts so there's something
called direct certification and there
was proposals last year to explore the
idea of using Medicaid data to directly
certify students in our schools as fnr
eligible based on the income data we
have from Medicaid or based on Medicaid
eligibility
um so that is a program that the
department would uh it's a it's a it's a
pilot program so it's uh done on an
application by application basis for
each state uh
if we were to enter that program say
before the next deadline which I believe
is going to be September 2023 it would
impact fiscal year 26 adequacy I have
received some new numbers from DHHS I'm
I'm hesitant to throw a number out there
but I'll I'll take I'll take a guess so
this is a really rough estimate I've
received new numbers from DHHS and um
I'm going to play with this estimate a
little bit more and we're doing a if we
get an official fiscal note I'll work
with the LBA to to fine tune this number
but right now the number I looked at I
did some up math it was 42 million
um it would cost 42 million in the
current Formula but I do need to analyze
that a little bit more and and spend
some time looking at that number but
that's where I'm at currently with that
I hope our finance people look into that
representative Weiler
Rick along those lines yes yeah that
thank you Mr chair and thanks Mark for
uh for uh for doing that uh that
analytical work
um on um on Medicaid direct
certification
um are we also going to learn I mean
assuming we're going to hold um the that
differentiated Aid category let's just
say flat in terms of
um contribution to adequacy Dollars
obviously the distribution of it would
be depending upon
how Medicaid you know what the Medicaid
counts are versus the free and reduced
price lunch by so some communities might
see ups and downs is the is the analysis
going to include that when I was
crunching those numbers I assumed every
Medicaid student is already on f r so
there's a lot of assumptions that
analysis and it's really that's why it's
I'm throwing out that number it it is
this could be aspects of the number that
are problematic so when you uh if if
that bill does come before the committee
we'll have a more in-depth conversation
and I'll have probably more to share
about my analysis and what my analysis
can predict and not predict um but yeah
it's a it's a thorny issue just modeling
it out is uh sure no and thank thanks in
advance for the work on that and I I
believe Rick there are there's a house
bill there is a house and a Senate bill
and the Senate bill and we see a
significant drop in fnr in the high
school where high school students are
not participating and we're losing out
on all those dollars
so we need to get on top of that one
yes reps and Ellison and then
represented my wife thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mark for being
here uh just a a question about a page
two line one uh the local taxation
percentage which runs through the three
fiscal years that are there do you have
any sense and it runs about 60 percent
do you have any sense of where New
Hampshire sits on a chart of money
provided by local communities for
schools versus money provided by the
state I I can't give you uh an exact
ranking um but it's it's up it's we
we're sometimes we're I think we're
number one
um uh number one as far as um uh uh or
sorry number one for local taxation
contributing to our schools
um but yeah we're for most for Most
states um uh where or a property tax
state and so you can see a lot of
metrics out there people analyzing
property taxes across all 50 states and
New Hampshire has higher property taxes
than most other states thank you
representative Wiley you're talking
about free and reduce
people are supposed to pay something
when it's reduced most of them don't and
what's the percentage between free and
reduced
oh well I know that I believe the
poverty percentage as far as like the
actual numbers and counts I don't have
but um I believe free is 135 percent of
the federal poverty guideline I'm I
believe so and then reduced is 185
percent of the federal poverty guideline
out of those when you go to Medicaid and
these the things at 10. are those just
for free are they also include if you do
just
and snap
windows are all considered free but when
we go to Medicaid I do believe we're
going to have to parse information into
free and reduced we don't know all the
logistics in that program right now
because we're not participating in it so
if we begin to participate we'll get
more information
Okay so we've got to kind of find the
line in there in several schools I think
have come to Western said nobody ever
pays to reduce 30 and 40 000. deficits
because
if some of the person is getting free
I'm not paying either even though I do
just want to point out that is only for
the purpose of the meal reimbursement
though for the schools as far as the
differentiated Aid there's poverty is
exactly
yes the filing period with USDA still
open
until July
are there further questions
I want to thank you very much Mark and
Caitlin
and Amy uh it's been very informative uh
it's good overview there's a lot more
down there in the in the weeds uh but we
look forward to working with you on on
the 17th
and seeing you here at Furious hearings
and I appreciate the Senate and folks
coming in from Finance
um and and
Senate Ed for participating today I
think this is I wish we could do this
for all our reps
yeah thank you so we're going to take
about you know a few minute break here
and then we're going to come back as an
education committee we're going to talk
about some of the procedures and
protocols and then break for lunch and
after lunch we have the
school boards Association School excuse
me the first two are the higher
education chancellors coming in from uh
in the college President Jim Dean from
the UNH and Kathy provincher who used to
be our Treasurer and then we have Mark
Rubinstein a company coming in community
college system followed by the school
boards Association of the school
administrators Association Nea and aft
so we'll we'll take a five or ten minute
break here come back and we'll do about
20 minutes of procedures then we'll
yellow mangial
that's that's always been a hard one for
me
foreign
and finish this off right here at least
the morning portion if we can this part
should uh be relatively uh simple for us
I'd like to go through a couple of the
procedures and protocols that we as a
body should follow as we're getting into
the hearing executive committee process
especially in the hearing process the
executive sessions are meetings for us
to make the decisions on a bill the
hearings are for us to hear the voice of
the people and and receive that
testimony so I just have a couple things
I like to you know just reiterate or
state those that were here on the
orientation for newly elected you
probably have heard it but you know if
you're like myself it takes two or three
times at least that's with my wife when
I'm listening to her to really
comprehend what's being said and so so I
shouldn't have said that I know
I'm on my phone my mic's on but I'm
always you know in the corner
so uh and some of the procedures we
should be aware of uh I've had
committees here you know I I've been on
this one now for 14 this going to my
15th year on education I've chaired it
this for six years previously
um whenever you get a governor walking
in we will stand up immediately it's a
courtesy or the governor's wife uh or a
chief justice or somebody of that nature
we we want to respect the position uh
and the in the individual so if uh they
come in please respect and and stand up
um when we have testimony going on I
will always ask for if there's a senator
in the room that's a co-sponsor on that
get them up and done quickly there's
only 24 of them and they got a lot of
different committees that they're on so
we want to get them in and get them out
there was some discussion on the floor
the other day regarding should there be
time limits placed on folks which are
testifying
that that's an issue which really needs
a lot of judgment and consideration for
example if somebody's coming in for
example reps on luno has a bill it was
1680 last year it's the finance bill and
if he's introducing that it's going to
take him more than three minutes away
through you know 10 14 pages and let us
identify what is new what how word this
works and that works and so I will allow
those people that are prime sponsors to
have some time to present their bills if
we don't get it explained properly the
beginning will be going on and on and on
and maybe maybe uh uh making decisions
on subjective information rather than
really objective stuff that we could
have gotten earlier and oftentimes
there's people that come in that have
technical advice be it the school boards
Association or doe or some agency
Homeland Security we've had them in here
um it might be wise in some cases to
have them come up front and stay at few
things first or maybe at the end but we
will have technical advice given to us
and that really helps a significant
amount saves a lot of time
so you see me jumping around like that
now if for example on Thursday next week
we have a bill coming up which is
scheduled for reps Hall
we may have a lot of people we may not
but we've had bills before where we've
had that reps hall for Education totally
filled
obviously then you have to set time
limits and and there have been times so
when they initially get in there there's
not that many then all of a sudden more
come in and you're going to have to set
the time limits up I always make a point
to try and get those people that drove a
long way from Berlin
or up Cobra Pittsburgh or down on the
border to get up and and present and get
testimony and try to get out also those
that are families with young kids will
try and get them taken care of it's hard
for some of these young kids to stay out
there for two hours three hours waiting
for their mom or their dad
or whomever they would to testify so
we'll we we'll jump around a little bit
so there is it's I guess one shoe
doesn't fit all and that's what we try
to use a little common sense
um going on down here
we're gonna have some early bills coming
up and people ask me uh are we going to
be able to identify specific dates in
which we will be meeting at in the
hearings
are too exact uh we will have a better
handle that once we know all these bills
if we have bills that come in with a
financial note attached to them they're
going to be an early bill that means
we've got to clean them up and get out
of here quickly so we may have to have
some days which are really not really
announced there will always be put in
the calendar and we'll have to live by
the the the proper notice for the public
but uh initially I'm going to try and
stay away from Mondays so if you have
doctor's appointments and something
going on you know that might be a date
uh or I I know that folks like to use
Fridays attached to those long they'll
make the weekend a little longer and you
deserve it I'll try and work that way
too but we should have a better handle
on this within the next several weeks
and I'll I'll be able to tell you
specifically but for right now try to
count on Mondays even though there's
going to be other committees and
commissions I know I was just talking
representative Cornell here and she's
looking at a book schedule coming up
seeing there's some counsel she like is
it the CTE
yeah yeah and then we had legislative
oversight then on the next day and
there's these commissions and committees
going on all the time if anybody wants
to be on a committee or commission let
us know because we're glad to put you on
uh some of us are on tilt as a result of
that
um going on down some of the things
which we have here
um all familiar with the orange badges
those are the lobbyists
now when we're in to a middle of a
hearing or start of a hearing I want
everybody to be cautious I don't want to
hear any would you believe type
questions in other words sometimes we
don't have a specific question to ask
them would you believe that I feel this
that's not a question and so we're going
to steer away from that stuff there's
the smiling face out there from one of
our attorneys and and so what we want to
do is ask good questions we don't want
to get into a debate with the test those
people testifying they're here to
present their position and we're here to
listen we're here to listen and yes you
may have some judgments made on it but
that's something you don't want to
impart during the hearing process
you want to be able to ask good direct
questions yes but be careful not to get
into a debate with the person that's
there and all questions asked of course
have to come to the chair other words
you have to wave your hand or and
sometimes it's difficult for the chair
to see down for example I can't see
represent Tanner right now
um representative likes to put his hands
over like this but but uh but so you
have to stick your hand out please and
Glenn will try to watch and I will to to
make sure that we're we're noticing you
and recognizing you
um if you have a follow-up question
for the person that you've asked your
first question to and that's it's
logical it happens
um just remember that follow you have to
ask permission for the follow-up
question
ninety percent of the time I'll say go
for it
all right
um
while we're in in session here and we're
streaming for the public
when we you talk with each other we
should use the word representative X
representative Y and and I have I have
failed at that myself many many times
we've been working together for so long
some of us are friends here and we get
used to you know the the ex-speaker of
the house who has a camp up in Bethlehem
and lives here in Concord he and I met
each other on the trail climbing up and
up to Lonesome Lake in France uh
Franconia Notch and so we hike together
and we're just you know each first names
but when you get down here it's Mr
Speaker
our representative
so um let's let's try to adhere to that
um if you have a conflict of interest on
some particular bill uh let me know and
and if you feel you can't vote for some
reason on a bill but the thing is
there's no abstention in a subcommittee
it's either up or it's down
and when you're when I'm calling the
vote and in that the clerk will then say
here's the motion read off the title so
we know what you're voting on even if
it's amended we've got to have the
amendment number as well
the response should be yes you're for it
or no or yay or nay
um I don't want to have a lot of
dialogue attached to a well it's an a
with a lot of thought and a concern I
don't want to hear it it's either up or
down
please
so we can expedite things
um
I've given you uh a little packet of
materials here I'm not going to go
through it you you y'all are it sounds
like everybody's got a lot of experience
in education or well educated or
educating our kids or you can read it
and look it over
um if you have any questions please let
me know and I'd be glad to help you out
or let anybody else your ranking a
member the ranking member is
representative Miler here the vice
chairs representative cordelli and the
clerk to be maybe is Oliver four
representative Oliver Ford here
um he's come on with his dirty socks and
all that and
that he referenced here
um but no uh the clerk's job is a job
which is an important job it's what's
you know recorded during these meetings
and you can have people come in and they
want to know what's going on they can
ask to look at the record and those
notes are there the clerk does not jot
down verbatim everything that's said
they're looking primarily from upstairs
where they look at the stuff bullets
this was said this was said this was
said you know and that's what Clark has
to do is record that but it's a very
important statutory position
uh opening up the questions right now if
anybody has questions representative uh
uh thank you representative blood I
think it's important for the committee
to note
that this is a policy committee
we deal with policy
and that's an important distinction here
because we don't deal with Finance now
that doesn't mean we're not concerned
about the cost of a particular bill
but if the bill comes before us that has
a fiscal note to it it's ultimately
going to go to the finance committee and
they make the final judgment so if they
get a policy question from us that has a
fiscal note to it they'll then say well
you know we like the policy but we just
can't pay for it
so I think it's important for this
committee to look at the policy question
here what is the intent of a particular
bill
it's always in my mind's eye the first
question I'm going to ask is what's the
intent because sometimes you'll get a
bill that's that's very detailed but you
lose what is its purpose because to me
it well if I know the intent it then
gives me the screen that I need to look
at the bill through uh so I think that's
an important important point to me I
thought that's technology
we have bills that come before us but
then they may go to another Kim I've had
times when a bill has gone to three
committees
it can go for example from here to
Judiciary from Judiciary into Ways and
Means or into Finance uh so that that
will occur there it's hard to really
devoid yourself of looking at Finance
for example today we were talking about
differentiated Aid one of those
components there special education
the issue that I have boiling in my head
all the time is
it some children have a special need
which is
needing attendant attending to all day
long with Specialists others may be
there for two half hours a week maybe
it's a an articulation problem in the
younger grade and then with a bunch of
other kindergarten kids or first grade
kids
it costs a whole lot more to educate
that child that's getting 24 7 type
special education we do have
catastrophic our special education Aid
now that cuts in but that cuts in way
after the district spent a whole load of
money
and so do we need to wait
those categories or wait something so
that there's some like many other states
I so that's a policy that blends in with
Finance
so so yes I agree with what
representative Meyer said the the
finance is finance and we are policy but
policy and Finance on Fast learned you
can't always forget it you know you're
devoid it we've had a number of meetings
where we've been invited Finance in here
and been a part of a hearing process
uh that's not uncommon that's very
commonly done so good point
representative Miler representative you
had your hand up also yeah thanks thanks
very much Mr chair all right just a
quick question are we going to have
exclusive um use of this room yes we are
going to have exclusive use of this room
we are the only committee that has been
assigned one double room for the entire
year that that is absolutely needed when
we're talking last year we had 139 bills
in that one year and this year it's
quite possible where might break that
record we could break that record right
I tried the other day on the house floor
to get one vacated and we did get a
vacated one bill
um so yeah I mentioned to the speaker
I'd like to vacate 100 of them and so so
so in addition to the drawers for
storing things we can leave from night
to night like you know if they're not if
there's not going to be dust cleaning if
we can leave some material yeah the only
question would be the desk cleaner
because with with uh covet and
everything else there's been a need just
like you do in the schools for
superintendent
um you have to do a cleaning job and so
but we'll be told that day when they do
that and vacuuming is another thing
which they're trying to get around we do
have the file cabinets out there and we
used to have all the files for this
committee filed in that room we now have
a Legislative Assistant
um well Jennifer Forrest here she's our
researcher and she's always here and Jen
Jen is fabulous Jen came in I first met
her when she came in from Hawaii
and she's an attorney and she worked
with special ed services over at doe
White
and and now she's here and she's just
really upgraded our support and given us
a lot of ability to research and but
she's not the person responsible for
doing our scheduling
that's Lindsay and Lindsay is going to
be his house down the hallway and she we
used to have our Legislative Assistant
right in this room in here but because
we have the double rooms now we've
pushed those people down the hallway a
little bit that's where our scheduling
is done
um so all the files are kept down the
hallway as well
so you have a file drawer in there which
is identify with your name you can leave
the the some of the materials that I
always like to have I always like this
one I know this is representative
Tanner's thing
um to get copies of this book and I I
concur with her I think we all need a
copy but I'm a lot like uh
attorney Fenton back there who has all
these slips marking 193 194 CD whatever
it might be I got it right there and
um so it's I always have at my desk here
but I don't want to leave it there so I
put in the drawer out there
it's hard to carry this thing back and
forth from the home uh I also will try
to get everybody a copy of ed306 so
those the the rules for minimum
standards for public school approval
they are just as important to be looking
at that as it is the statutes we've
given doe the State Board I mean
authority to write rules in support of
the laws which we pass and and so those
rules are really important to look at
and become familiar with even though
there's efforts on the sidelines
somewhere where they're trying to
rewrite ed306 we're looking at three
academic standards and minimum standards
for public school approval we have a
legislative oversight committee starting
up next Tuesday at Tuesday on that one
um see where we are in that I I really
don't know where we are on that I'm
trying to get a better handle on it
academic standards are the key to it all
and the minimum Public School standards
are equally as important so we'll we'll
go there then
um any other questions
or information that's needed yes
representative Mr chair I think you make
an important point that people might not
be aware of that when a bill is passed
rules are then made to implement that
that law
and that's that's what Rick is referring
to it that's very important in the 306th
comes up for review every 10 years yeah
every 10 years and so we're in that
phase right now where these rules are
being looked at by the department and
they've been working on it for about two
years now and it's coming coming to the
end of that review where you get a lot
more public input for it too but the
rules are important because it basically
takes the intent of the bill and says
how is it going to be applied
academic standards cannot be adopted by
the state board
without approval from us
so that we put into law last year has
come before the legislative oversight
committee also if you look at 193 under
the adequacy every 10 rules our academic
standards which are adopted after a
certain date require General Court
approval
so um
representative are representative
sure
um
right uh my name is
I'm an attorney with the Department of
Education it's very nice to be here in
front of all of you I just want to
elaborate on that rule making process
representative Miler said when a law is
passed in there are rules there are only
rules created when the law says rule
making authority pursuant to RSA 541a
and what we have found is from time to
time there are areas where it says where
it has that rule making Authority but it
really mimics what the law already says
it was a law passed last session about
um
water fountains or water water bottle
stations in in schools but it was
already laid out in the law and there
was really no need for the rules it
would be redundant
um the opposite of that is when a law is
passed
and there is no rule-making Authority
but it talks about guidance or
guidelines and and there needs to be
things that are fleshed out
and so it's important to take that into
consideration when you look at these
laws that are coming before you the
department cannot just go into rule
making it needs that authority to do so
and the rule making really needs to be
enumerated as to what this legislative
body wants those rules to entail
I'm happy to take any questions or talk
about that rulemaking process but those
are some of the things we've seen at the
department when we are putting the laws
into practice
there are times when we we use this 541a
and we
we refer back to a whole section of our
chapter of law which is wrong we have to
reference back to specific areas that
they're responsible for making these
rules I can remember when we passed the
legislation for the fourth year of
mathematics in high school it's embedded
it's not a requirement for graduation
The Way It Was Written in statute there
was no need for rules they just took
what was in the statute and that became
how you do things and so yeah we we well
we want to stop the rule making process
if we can it's it's I don't know if we
want to stop it I'll not stop it we're
getting on overload though we want to be
mindful of how we utilize it and I think
a great example of the rulemaking
process is representative Lads bill that
was passed a few sessions ago as it
pertains to the code of conduct in the
code of ethics which you're probably
very familiar with
um if you look at 21
N9 subsection S I believe it said code
of conduct which would have four
principles in an IT enumerated the four
principles but then it deferred to rule
making to flush out those four
principles and the department can
provide this legislative body with the
code of conduct but it is very detailed
and I think that's a great example of
the rulemaking process if you think of
the statute as the foundation of the
house the frame of the house the roof of
the house and then the rule making are
the interior
design right the couches the drapes the
things like that it flushes out the
process and I think the code of conduct
is a great example of that thank you
are there any questions for Diana Fenton
Shield she'll be around she's
she's here and
um she's very very helpful she's a prior
prosecutor so don't mess around with her
yeah don't hold that against me thank
you thank you very much I appreciate
your time so lastly the other thing that
some people ask me about amendments
we will get a lot of bills our job here
is to pass good bills if we think we can
make it a better Bill we should try to
do that
but if it's going to take an
extraordinary amount of work
and and we know that a subcommittee is
not going to be able to do it it's not
worth trying to you know
Hammer something into it and make it
work because we'll probably end up
making it worse and and
enacting legislation which then requires
a lot it not requires results and
confusion out there in the schools so we
can make amendments we do make
amendments I encourage people to do that
if somebody hands you an amendment say I
want you to handle that as a Committee
Member you can introduce an amendment
but the individual out in the crowd
cannot introduce a limit to this
committee it has to be presented to us
by a member on this committee
so and you can get the Amendments made
uh across the street where legislative
Services is still and they can have that
emailed over to a committee Services
upstairs and they make copies that's
Jennifer does that and brings those
amendments down here
if you are looking at amendments try
work with your ranking uh you know a
person or the or the vice chair myself
so that we will know that's coming at us
and so we can you know handle it
properly
reps and lockers
yeah a question concerning amendments if
we
um let's say we put in a bill or
co-sponsored a bill or whatever and then
later realize that it really wasn't
right that maybe referenced a different
section than we intended or whatever and
we don't realize it in time
if we get that Amendment written up very
early
can we introduce it
at the uh you know when when the bill is
actually introduced if we've put it out
and let everybody know here's the
amendment this is really what we wanted
it to say can we do that or what is the
there are a number of bills which are
going to come at us which are still lsrs
legislative service requests
and
if you encountered the the the new folks
over in uh office legislative Services
right now all the people drafting bills
a good part of them are new and all the
folks in the office as you walk in aside
from one are new and so they're jumping
through some hoops which are new for
them and so we're getting uh
lsrs handed back to us from OLS
sometimes the day before you have to
have all your sponsors on and every time
you have you make a modification it's a
different version to that bill
that will require them to send that out
and get approval of all the co-sponsors
even though the co-sponsors initially
approved the original version if you
change a version all that other stuff's
thrown out because they're having you're
having to approve now the new version
which may be very different
so uh we're going to see bills coming in
now this year I know there's several
that I've had that are not out yet that
gone by the date and and you may only
have one or two people as the signing
off on that bill that I have time to do
it doesn't mean just because there's
only one person the bill is not doesn't
have any Merit it means it's probably
gone through some stuff over there where
it's just come out late and we couldn't
get all the names on that and that's
going to be frequent so now when you
bring that forward you may see here's an
amendment to that bill I I to improve it
you can win your testifying presenting
it you can also say I have an amendment
here I will present it with my testimony
here and we as a committee can look at
that it may may help so that's a good
point representative
anything else okay right now we have my
cell phone doesn't work when I come to
Concord I don't know why Verizon
um what time is it
okay let's break right now and come back
at one o'clock
and at that time we're going to have
higher education in here for that hour
half hour for our University system the
other for the community college system
we work very closely with those folks
all their policy issues have to come
before this committee and where we've
been merging programs over there and
courses that are taught in the community
college and the leading up to it that's
we we do that here that has to be
approved through this it's all stat
story so it's important that we hear
from thank you very much I've enjoyed
working with you this morning learning a
lot a lot of good expertise here it
should be a great year thanks
I'm just seeing her away
I like to get uh going here on the
second part of today's orientation
meeting as I mentioned earlier
um this afternoon we had the higher
education and then we have School Board
Association School administrators
Association and the Nea and aft
we do have both parties here higher
education University system and you're
not even sitting together
what happened to that merger we were
supposed to have
okay
um just another one other thing I was
asked by several people during the break
is it okay to have water or fluids here
yes
you know we've been told by all the
medical doctors keep drinking as much as
you can in here so if you want to bring
water and I you don't have to put in the
floor we tried that trick once before
and everybody was kicking the cans over
and then we got nailed because the
stains on the floor so if you have a
beverage you want to drink just make
don't look at me like that
accessible yes yeah that's fine that's
fine okay with that I'd like to go ahead
and open up this afternoon session we
have higher education University system
I welcome president Jim Dean and Kathy
provincher Tom are you also coming up on
that or
you're okay
welcome
you got to hit the red butt and the
president
we got it thank you representative Vlad
and good afternoon everyone happy to
have the opportunity to talk with you as
representative Ladd said I'm Jim Dean
I'm the president of the University of
New Hampshire and also the interim
Chancellor of the University system of
New Hampshire and this is Kathy
provencher who is both the Chief
Financial Officer and the chief
administrative officer for the
University system of New Hampshire and
then I think without our time is up
no we'll give you we're starting a
little late so you get another five
minutes Kathy used to be the treasurer
of the state as well right and does
everyone have the deck that we
distributed in front of them you have
access to that okay so I'm going to page
two of the deck and we'll go back and
forth a bit as we make the our comments
this afternoon so the uh page two of the
deck is is really the biggest and big
picture about who we are and who we
represent so as you can see there's the
statutory language at the top that talks
about this establishment of the
University system of New Hampshire to
provide a well-coordinated system of
public higher education serve the needs
of the state in the nation also research
which contributes to the welfare of
mankind and also bringing educational
resources and professional experience to
the benefit of the state and its people
so we have a pretty broad mandate
associated with education from the
statute we've given you sort of a mini
organizational chart there on the lower
left hand side and so the system the
university university system excuse me
of New Hampshire is just below the state
of New Hampshire and then we have the
three major institutions that are part
of of the University system and then a
few details below that we also have as
it says on the lower right hand side a
Board of Trustees and we've given you in
the italicized section there some idea
where the various members of the Board
of Trustees come from and then another
part of our leadership is the
president's Council which is the
president of the three institutions
and I know you all are meeting all day
today and have other days and you're
having an awful lot thrown at you so if
any of this is not clear feel free to I
mean we're here really to be helpful to
you so if there's something I say that
doesn't make sense you don't understand
it feel free to ask thank you and with
that I'll turn it together thanks Suman
good afternoon everyone and thanks for
inviting us we're
um always happy to answer any questions
of committee members the last slide has
contact information for president Dean
and myself I encourage all elected
officials to reach out directly if you
ever have any questions and
um for those of who have been on the
education committee for quite some time
some of this
um
is information you already are aware of
but understanding there are a number of
new members we want to really cover at a
high level information about the
um you know part of our statutory
mandate is to
um work toward and ensure a
well-coordinated system
and we have been recognized for our
strong financial management by Moody's
credit rating agency in um in late
November
um the entire higher education industry
is on negative watch
Moody's just put the industry on
negative watch and we were notified that
our Outlook was upgraded from negative
to stable in November and
um that's in large part because of the
really hard intensive work we've been
doing over the past three years to
streamline our administrative structure
rethink how the work is done and
um through doing so have reduced our
overall cost structure by about 50
million dollars between fiscal 19 and
22. you'll hear a little bit more this
afternoon about why that is absolutely
necessary for the University system
um with the challenges that higher
education in New England is facing over
the next decade so with that I'm going
to turn it back over to Jim to talk
about mission
foreign
okay thank you Kathy so on on page four
we talk about uh the workforce needs of
the state and together with our
colleagues from the community colleges
we do an awful lot to prepare people to
be part of the workforce I know that
Workforce is a huge concern for the
state and for all the businesses within
it so we just wanted to give you a
couple of Statistics there that we
thought might be helpful
so just within the graduating classes of
of eight years from 2012 to 2020
1800 graduates of the University system
are working in the state as part of the
workforce obviously there's many more
than that if you go back through other
years but we wanted to just give you
sort of a sense of you know even
recently how many people are joining the
workforce in New Hampshire who are
graduates from the various institutions
that are that are part of the system
we don't do this in a vacuum and so we
collaborate in a lot of ways with the
businesses in the uh in the state and so
you can see the other number that we put
there is that we have over 2 000
partners of businesses in the state with
whom we work closely actually we have a
number of councils and various other
kinds of relationships uh to stay close
to the workforce needs of the state I
have a business advisory Council that
advises me as president of the
University of New Hampshire of a number
of businesses from around the state and
I've also joined about two years ago the
Executive Board of the business and
industry Association so we do an awful
lot to stay close to the needs of the
businesses in the state and we see
ourselves a really important part of our
mission as being to try and provide
qualified people to help the business
community in New Hampshire to achieve
their goals
I'm going to apologize to those of you
who are behind this speaker here I'll
try to move around a little bit on page
five we talked just a little bit about
the research Mission uh of the system
um much of it is at UNH because UNH is
is a the research University in the
system but other research is done at all
of the institutions so UNH is indeed
what's known as a Carnegie one or the
first highest level of research
University in the country a leading
research institution bringing as it says
over 260 million dollars in competitive
research funding to New Hampshire in
2021 so that funding comes into the
university and it supports people who
are doing that research it supports
things that we have to buy equipment
telescopes boats literally ships all
kinds of things but we also then employ
a lot of people who support that
research so the research that comes in
and all of this research is coming in
competitively from the federal
government including the National
Science Foundation NOAA National
Institutes of Health and so on benefits
the economy in New Hampshire so it's
really important that we talk about that
that is an important part of what the
we also as it says through the epscor
program build research capacity through
educational institutions across the
state investments in infrastructure the
workforce and early stage academic
research this is a huge Enterprise
within the university system
um far too big to really do justice too
in the time that we have available but
we certainly stand ready to give
additional information if that would be
helpful
moving then to Page Six
we talk a little bit about Student
Success and Student Success is a bit of
a complicated uh point or a complicated
construct but one of the elements of
Student Success that's really important
is the graduation rate and the people
who monitor graduation rate
um through the iPad system which is in
the footnotes here I've decided that
they use it for a six years graduation
rate as opposed to a four-year
graduation rate many students across the
country take longer than four years to
graduate so they take they use six years
as The Benchmark that's their decision
not ours as you can see the institutions
in the University system do rather well
against that Benchmark so you see the
other states in New England made Rhode
Island Massachusetts Connecticut Vermont
and our graduation rate is higher than
any of those which is something that
we're really proud of so one of the
things that you've probably read about
is is the challenges with student debt
students who take out loans and we'll
talk about that just in one second but
really the worst case for a student is
to borrow money for his or her education
and then not graduate because then
they're not able to get the kind of job
that allows them to pay that debt back
and the higher your graduation rate is
then the better off you are from that
standpoint so we're really proud of that
having said that we believe that could
be higher in all of the institutions
have programs in place in order to
continue to make that graduation rate uh
met graduation rate higher on the right
side you have the student loan default
rate and that's also something that
we're very proud of again looking at
various competitors our student loan
default rate which is a measure of
students literally not being able to pay
back their loans is quite a bit lower
than the U.S average the public average
the Northeast average and so what that
means is that the preparation that we're
providing for students in the system is
such that it allows them to go out and
get jobs which allow them to pay back
their loans and again that's something
moving then to page seven
I think this is a really important point
that we've had five years in which we
have not increased tuition for students
coming from New Hampshire and there
aren't very many universities in the
country that could make that claim
um
this is at a time as you know we're
we're in an inflationary environment
especially the last couple of years and
so when we are keeping tuition flat it's
in real dollars it's effectively
I also want to point out as it says in
the bold face below the chart that the
granite guarantee covers full tuition
for New Hampshire students with
exceptional need which means that those
students who are qualified for Pell
Grants grants to those students who come
from families with limited resources
that those students actually pay no
tuition now I need a hasten to say that
doesn't mean that college is free for
them because there's residence halls and
there's food and there's books and
things like that but this is a
commitment that we made a number of
years ago that our poor students would
not have to pay any tuition and that
makes a tremendous difference for them
they're being able to complete that's
probably partly responsible for their
completion rate and also their ability
to pay to pay back any loans that they
might have taken
so flat tuition for five years and
increasing financial aid so the real
cost to students has actually gone down
over the past few years for the
institutions in our system
and then finally before I turn it back
to Kathy on page eight I'll talk about
Cooperative Extension and what we're
doing to bring other resources into the
state we're really proud of our
Cooperative Extension program as you may
know UNH is a land-grant institution
which means that we'll have Cooperative
Extension we have people out around the
state doing the kind of traditional
things you would expect of Cooperative
Extension I just visited within apple
orchard a couple of months ago where we
had one of our scientists out there
helping the people who run the apple
orchard to figure out how to grow
peaches in New Hampshire so if you
thought you grow peaches in New
Hampshire raise your hand because I sure
didn't I thought that was a losing
proposition but science has a way and so
apparently we are now growing peaches in
New Hampshire and I had one it wasn't
bad actually so so that's the really
kind of traditional thing we do but we
do a lot of other things that are much
less traditional around Workforce we've
worked a lot with various communities
across New Hampshire to help them do
Economic Development to bring tourism
and economic sustainability
uh the Small Business Development Center
does a lot of work that's where big
businesses come from is is small
businesses and an awful lot of
professional development just helping
people to learn the skills that they
need to run whether it be a business or
whether it be a not-for-profit or to
participate in the economy and in some
other ways so this whole Cooperative
Extension area and the associate areas
that are not the Core teaching
undergraduates or even graduate students
I wanted to make sure we highlighted
that because I think they're really
important to the well-being of the state
and with that Kathy I'll turn it back to
you great thanks Jim so so Jim shared
with you all the good news
and and I'm going to share with you some
of the challenging news
so um You probably seen on the news read
in the paper
um higher education especially in New
England
is facing some pretty serious headwinds
as a primarily as a result of
demographic shifts you know from um well
maybe you haven't had that part of your
orientation yet but you know that the
K-12 population is on the decline
and that is a pipeline for those that
will attend a
institutions of Higher Learning and then
be part of our Workforce so the
demographic challenges are not solely in
New Hampshire they're in the entire
region which is causing incredible
competition
amongst the New England and New York now
States for college-going students to
support
their Workforce all of that means that
enrollment is on the decline we have
been preparing for it for quite some
time that's why I talked earlier about
what do we need to do to decrease our
cost structure when we don't have as
many students and as much tuition in
tuition dollars we need to think about
how our cost structure is set up so
changing demographics intense
competition and we have low State
support in relation to our peers around
New England and around the country we
well geez if I would have flipped
forward I could have told you there's
your there's your K-12 slide no I I knew
it was there
um but again this is this this has a
direct impact on the number of college
goers
and then the number of college educated
people who will enter our Workforce so
it's it's all connected and then on
slide 11 you can see that New Hampshire
if you measure per capita or your
measure per thousand dollars in income
all the of all 50 states
New Hampshire is that the is the 50th
and that that directly correlates to the
reason that we have high in-state
tuition in relation to other states
around the country
um the the state support
buys down that in-state tuition when
slide 12. these are examples of
the intense competition
um Tom drove by he was in Rochester
coming down the Spalding Turnpike and
there were two Billboards one for human
the University of Maine and one for was
it SUNY
like uh perpendicular to one another
saying come to our institutions for the
same price as your in-state tuition in
New Hampshire
the sunnis the State University system
in New York
they have a full on
100 million dollar campaign to blast the
entire region in an effort to pull
students from New England to the Sunni
system and will offer go there for less
than you'd pay at in-state tuition and
UNH again the point is the competition
is really intense
and on slide 13
um
this is just a history of the state of I
know this is a the policy committee for
education but I think it's important to
um outline the state support for the
University system about eight percent of
our total budget
comes from state general fund
Appropriations
and so our request for fiscal years 24
and 25
is to get back to where we were in 2011.
and we have some targeted
requests that we'll be making relative
to
um internship capacity and
um the the programs that PL at Keene and
the programs at Plymouth where the
students go out into the community work
with the businesses work with the
non-profits you may have seen it on the
news that there were a group of students
that were up in the North Country
working on a project with the mill
property we really want to to bolster
that work at Plymouth and Keene
and with that there's contact
information I also want to mention we
did put a couple of slides in the
appendix relative to ongoing work from
legislation in the last session that's
the Granite State College merger
um Granite State College is being merged
into the University of New Hampshire as
a as a college within the university and
also HB 1530 representative Ford very
familiar with that piece of legislation
there's a slide of the ongoing work that
the university system is doing with the
community college system relative to
transfer Pathways between those two
systems and with that
we're happy to answer any questions that
you folks have of us thank you very much
I'll open up with one question for your
request for information uh I've often
heard that New Hampshire is an exporter
of high school students to other states
for college
um where I've heard that 60 percent of
our graduates go outside uh that's a
rough percentage is there anything we're
doing to try to reverse that Trend to
keep these folks that are in high school
well that Grant guarantee is one
initiative if you will to try to to try
to keep
um
students here in New Hampshire
um I know that
um actually you may
sure so the granite guarantee is
certainly one for our poor students uh
also keeping our tuition flat for five
years in a row makes us more competitive
for our students for in-state tuition
flat and we also then have various
scholarship programs we have for example
the Hamill Scholars Program which is
available to the highest achieving
students only from New Hampshire to try
and keep those students here the
challenge is is because of the low State
support our tuition is higher than we
wish it were and that that leads
students to leave
and the number of students who left the
state dramatically increased when our
funding was cut 10 years ago yeah I I
know that up in Woodsville at Walmart
there's a 18-wheeler up there
Budweiser on one side and the other side
said go black bears
so that's how Humane is competing
you know through that getting to the
eyes right up there yep
yes represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair um I I just had a
question on on as far as the state
support issue and I'm certainly sure
that it's true that you probably receive
less compared to other New England
regions I'm looking also if you have any
information on other causes
um as far as tuition being high for
instance I didn't see any statistics in
this handout about say
um the ratios of uh professors to
administrative Personnel now compared to
perhaps 30 years ago and if that's
sure we always do we always do look at
those kind of things that we can get
just some additional information about
that I will say that across the board
nationally those ratios have been
changing in favor of Administrators just
to give you one example so uh Title IX
Title IX as it's been reinterpreted
first by the Obama Administration then
the Trump Administration not the Biden
Administration has cost each institution
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
staff support in order to comply with
those kinds of uh basically unfunded
mandates is effectively what they are
the other thing we're seeing is that
student needs for things outside the
classroom have dramatically increased uh
you've probably read that there's a
mental health crisis among college
students so we have been in the position
of pretty dramatically increasing the
number of counselors that we provide to
students over the last few years so
those would be two examples of why some
represented I actually have some I
actually have some numbers so
um
the university system spends about
thirty one hundred dollars annually per
student on day-to-day operational
expenses
knowing other New England four-year
Publix
41.50 so we have one of the lowest
administrative costs per student
in New England and again this effort
starting in 2019 to really drive down
administrative costs even further
through
leveraging scale in everything
administrative that we could grab onto
and that work does not stop we know we
have to continue that work so it is a
top of mind sorry to interrupt you
you have a follow-up yes just briefly
thank you Mr chair uh just just one more
number I'd be interested in to help me
understand the needs better do you
happen to know the
um the levels of the endowments of the
three colleges Universities at how where
foreign yes we can absolutely get that
for you I can tell you that
unh's endowment is much healthier than
keen and Plymouth
UNH has been very successful in its
fundraising efforts in recent years
um
I as to I will get that for you
and so let me just say it's a great
question thank you for that uh the
number one uh
Target of fundraising and then the
number one area of the gifts that we get
is for student scholarships so the main
focus of philanthropy is actually to
hold down the expense for our students
representative miler
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I have three questions primarily focused
on students
one is how many are in your guaranteed
program
how many students are in the guaranteed
program your credit guarantee yeah
granted guarantee excuse me secondly is
what is the strategy of the university
in combating the onslaught from Maine
and from New York as you what's your
strategy to deal with that and finally
what is the current in-state out of
state to uh student population at the at
UNH particularly
okay let me take the third one first uh
the last one the last figures I saw were
about 52 out of state and about 48 in
state at UNH it changes every year yeah
a little bit
um since we've been holding tuition flat
for New Hampshire students but not for
out-of-state students I expect that that
will probably change a little bit uh
over a period of time I don't know the
number of uh granted guarantee students
I'd have to look that up so we'll look
that up and get that back to you and I
would say that in terms of combating uh
the other states who are coming for us
trying to increase our funding so that
we can hold down our tuition is really
one of the main things because that's
what that's what they're beating us up
with are as they see it relatively High
in-state tuition having said that we
have recently made some investments in
enhancing our marketing to students to
try and combat that to try and help them
understand what the value of an
education is from you and UNH or from
Keen or from Plymouth so we're trying to
combat it from that standpoint as well
it's both priced and quality and just a
follow-up what is your student
population in the system now as it's
you have that in the fact book there
it's
it's all
as I mentioned it's on the decline hang
on just one second so in the fall
of 21. okay
our total full-time equivalence 22 800.
and in 18 five years earlier
twenty five thousand five hundred
thank you very much
now we've lost 50 000 kids K through 12
since I first got on this Committee in
the state of New Hampshire
that's a lot of students perhaps in
Woodcock did you have to
thank you Mr chairman um good afternoon
thank you for taking my question welcome
a couple questions that I'm not trying
to be buzzing at you just the number of
questions
um on the 18 800 on the workforce that
came back and stayed in hanfield the
last 10-year period how many how many
and I I have the number to stay here but
how many actually what was the big
population you pulled out
I I don't know representative we'll have
to get back to you because we have a man
do you have an annual like graduation
number over that time
for class basically
probably on the order about 4 000
something like that across the system
you know
I think it's probably less than four
thousand okay and the second one if I
made Mr Sheriff thank you
um on holding the uh tuitions flat to
the 10 year period
what has been the increase in in uh fees
um the fees generally increase in this
sort of one to two percent range a year
or something like that
um those are pretty direct things like
the cost of food in the dining halls and
residence hall costs and things like
that so they don't go up dramatically
they go up a small amount and we have a
really elaborate process of working with
the students uh to get their uh
their agreement for the most cases
they're just not always complete
agreement but for the most part the
students understand that they want the
students that they want the services
excuse me that the fees represent so
they're generally positive about the
season thank you thank you Mr chair
you're welcome
yes representative cardelli
thank you thank you uh both for being
here
um just to follow up on the discussion
about student debt and also the six-year
graduation rate it seems that in the
past few decades the number of students
who don't graduate in four years has
increased maybe I'm mistaken on that but
that's my impression do you have any
thoughts on the reasons for uh the
increased numbers of students or maybe
percentage of students not graduating in
well I can speak to the change but I'll
give you some sense of maybe some of the
reasons why they don't graduate I mean
so first of all some of them don't
graduate ever they right right they they
simply drop out some of them decide uh
that I mean some of it's economic uh you
know they they need to get a job and
they decide they needed to get a job now
there's some adverse set back in their
families and they need to support their
families there's certainly some of that
um for some of them they transfer to
other institutions and that then they
take a little longer to finish based on
that
um
for many of them it's it's events that
happen in their lives that take them
away that the death of a parent for
example a significant illness of a
parent something like that and then
there are some certainly who just don't
feel they can complete the academic work
or it's decided for them that you know
their their academic performance is poor
enough that they don't uh they're not
able to finish or not able to finish on
time we also have students who change
majors and if you change Majors once you
can probably make it work in four years
if you change twice you probably can't
so there's some of that as well
um and and finally some students really
enjoy being in college
and they they think five years is more
fun than four years we try to discourage
that in fact we've just made an
investment in this actually goes back to
your question representative Belcher
we've just made an investment in some
advisors to try and do a better job of
helping the students to finish on time
because it's a really important thing
for us because we want to limit their
debt
thank you and one last question right
here that I have
um
in looking at granted guarantee that
money has to come from somewhere to
support that program you're trying to
keep in-state tuition level
and you also have Capital costs which
are hitting you
um
not a very Rosy picture in terms of
dollars and cents I understand it and
we're also seeing that with uh jumping a
little bit with the teacher shortage
we're seeing many of our teachers coming
out that are math science special ed
going outside our state not remaining in
our state so things aren't Rosy here uh
from the money side uh
I know you're going to say well just
state fund us more
um but do you have any significant
Capital needs that are coming up on top
of uh what we've discussed here in terms
of uh costs for a student and granted
guarantee what are the capital things
we're looking at
like the PSU Keen UNH absolutely there
there are always significant Capital
needs we we're operating three little
cities
um however we are in the process of
evaluating our space needs as the number
of students decline
we have to think about the space that we
have we also have to think about does
the space we have meet the needs of the
students we have and the research we do
and the um
the things that are being taught today
right so yes there we we have the
university system funds about 60 60 to
65 million dollars a year in a capital
program
the
in the upcoming biennium
the state did a three biennium capital
program for us
to buy anything about this year the
state this biennium coming up the state
will fund 17 million dollars
in costs primarily for our biological
sciences initiative
largest prod Capital project ever
undertaken in the University system a 95
million dollar project to eliminate a
lot of deferred maintenance and expand
the life sciences
infrastructure and buildings at the
University so that at the University of
New Hampshire so that we can keep up
with with our our peers and what the
world today expects out of
Life Sciences so yes there are lots of
capital needs and we try to address them
the best we can prioritize as best we
can
thank you
one last question represent Woodcock and
then
thank you this will be my last question
thank you Mr chairman
um approximately how many uh the best
gifts you can
students coming in as freshman students
particularly are taking remedial four
um we don't we don't there's none
correct yeah so there's no remedial
classes being offered for amen thank you
yeah we've had that answered like that
in the past thank you thank you very
much we're going to get on with the
community college system appreciate you
taking the time out of the day to come
down president Dean and Kathy provincher
thank you always always glad to answer
for those who don't know uh Mark
Rubinstein is the chancellor of the
community college system New Hampshire
he was our past president of Granite
State College and started that wonderful
online program that they have and then
they moved over and he's now with a
two-year system and welcome Mark we
thank you representative Ladd first to
correct the record I can't take credit
for having started that program but did
serve that college for seven years and I
appreciate the opportunity to do that
just for uh Clarity there should be
presentation materials in front of you
that will look like this and I'm with uh
thanks to my colleague and director Reid
who helped prepare that and uh colleague
director Doran who's also with me for
college access programs I'm going to
probably go a little bit off script you
put together a presentation like this in
the quiet of your office thinking you
know how you want to script The
Narrative and then you have the
opportunity listen to questions from the
panel and realize that maybe the
interests are a little bit different so
I will make some reference to materials
here but more this is background
information for you community college
system has a Statewide Mission seven
colleges embedded in regions throughout
New Hampshire and really intended to
provide access visibility but as much as
that excuse me as much as that is to
understand the needs of individual
communities to understand what's
different about each of them and also
what's the same so that we can provide
resources that are appropriate
the students who we serve are in many
ways different from those that are
typically served at a four-year
Institution
only about 22 percent of our students
are 20 to 16 to 20 year old and this is
outside of our dual enrollment the high
school programs which I'll talk about in
a minute 40 of our enrollment are
students who are 25 and older and
typically working adults often parents
and you're going to see through the
materials as you look through some
vignettes some illustrations these are
folks who live in your community are
currently working and more likely than
not three quarters of our students are
part-time almost all of them working
taking care of parents or children or
other community responsibilities so
their opportunities are often different
than for students who who move directly
from high school to four-year
institutions
the ways in which we serve these
students a significant number are in
degree programs again primarily
part-time but but in degree programs
that are fairly traditional in the way
you would think about them in classroom
settings in clinical settings although
currently about a third of our
enrollment is actually occurring online
and gives us a more of a Statewide reach
and with a rollout of broadband across
New Hampshire we should be able to
amplify that we offer Workforce
Development programs short-term
credentialing programs that are relevant
to industries that help people make a
quick start into careers maybe one of
the most significant ways in which we
impact students in New Hampshire is
through our dual enrollment programs
about 8 000 students in a typical year
will be served you'll be familiar with
this perhaps through running start
um the way that I think about this
program for a student and within support
of the legislature some students pay
nothing for those credits that's
absorbed by a scholarship other students
pay fifty dollars a credit but in the
course of a typical year we estimate
that we're saving New Hampshire students
and families about seven and a half
million dollars in higher education
costs loans that they don't have to take
out that they don't have to worry about
and you'll see in the back of the pack
that we've talked about some of our
legislative priorities for this year
we're actually asking to expand what
we're able to do with dual enrollment
because we think that we can make that a
more Strategic investment in New
Hampshire as students
currently the scholarship program
available for students taking stem and
CTE courses limits them to two courses a
year we'd like to expand that to up to
five courses a year complementary to the
high school curriculum but allow a
student to finish a full year or more of
college level learning while still in
high school and again without incurring
the expense or the debt of doing that
forgive me not because we think every
student needs to go to a four-year
college or at least needs to go to a
four-year college right away but we
think that students need to have
opportunities in front of them and need
to not be saddled by the expense and the
barrier that cost per presents so we're
trying to leverage one of the things
that we know we can do well which is
help students get a head start in
whatever academic and career path that
they want
one of the consequences of this approach
of doing more with dual enrollment
helping students to save money helping
families to save money our programs and
our enrollment are increasingly
concentrated in areas that can't really
be delivered in that way
as you look through the packet one of
the slides that I'm particularly proud
of the programs where we do deliver over
the last 12 years over 3 400 nursing
degrees conferred by a community college
system it's a two-year program those
students can go on to complete a
bachelor's or Master's in nursing but
they're in the workforce in two years
and virtually all of them staying here
in New Hampshire because that's where
they live
too interestingly our nursing graduates
are disproportionately students in that
25 and older group and two-thirds of the
graduates it used to be three quarters
so it's it's starting to skew a little
bit younger but still decidedly these
are students who are coming back making
commitments in their communities but
because we're doing more with dual
enrollment about 22 and a half percent
of the courses we offer in dual
enrollment happen to be in math
significant share in English those are
not terribly expensive to be delivered
but of course it is in Dental in nursing
in Radiology those Automotive welding
you go through the list of programs that
are still concentrated with us that's
where the expense accrues and we no
longer have the ability to offset in
some ways and that's why we are so
appreciative of the support we have from
the state the ability to continue to
deliver the programs that we offer
particularly the growing concentration
in those expensive to deliver programs
is only possible because of the support
that that you've provided us
so I'm probably having gone through off
Off Script on this I've probably missed
more than a few things that are
important but if you've had a chance to
go through this list and there's this
packet and if there are questions the
committee has I'd be happy to answer
thank you very much Mark are there
questions from the committee for the
community college system yes uh
representative Myler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here and taking my question
because uh
students who enter as a freshman
can matriculate automatically to the
university system
how many students would you say or what
percent of your students actually Who
start as a freshman I'm not talking
about those who come back and get a
certificate Etc but those who are in an
academic program what percent of those
students do ultimately matriculate into
one of the University Systems schools
um in recent years
my time at Granny's day I was police say
granite state was the primary
destination a typical year would be
between 250 and 260 University roughly
the same Keenan Plymouth smaller numbers
in aggregate close to 700 students
transferring from the community college
system to the university system most
years
are there other
states that have the same kind of
matriculation uh process or are we
somewhat unique in that opportunity for
students
Most states have some form of
articulation in the State of Florida the
state of Virginia state of California
for years have used community colleges
as a way of managing the capacity
University education is typically more
expensive than community colleges and in
states with large populations and
particularly during periods of growth
they've used community colleges as a
more affordable entryway into four-year
education so Most states have some
structure like that you're welcome sir
Roxanne Belcher yeah did you end up
thank you Mr chair
um I'm looking just for a general idea
because we have obviously difficulty
with um Workforce problems here in New
Hampshire getting enough people and jobs
um of all the jobs that we have
available in New Hampshire the jobs that
we're having a hard time filling do you
have any concept of
um what percentage of those jobs might
be
um reasonably filled by the the type of
education that you would receive through
the community college system versus say
a higher degree
I'd be misleading to put a percentage I
would say most and you know one of the
things that's been interesting in in
recent years is to watch as the labor
markets become tighter employers have
become more open to Alternative
credentials and we're willing to train
willing to do on job learning and to
some degree that's one of the real
opportunities is to blend experiential
learning with what you can deliver
didactically either a classroom or
online for community colleges where
three quarters of our students are
already working adults are already
balancing work in life if we can help
take some foundational skills and
knowledge and put them into roles and
provide the additional education you
know again I'm not sure that there are a
whole lot of limitations that I've
mentioned nursing is example but we've
conferred in that same period of time
probably about 800 certificates in
accounting nearly a thousand in welding
we graduate CDL qualified drivers when
you go through whether it's Department
of Transportation or administrative
Services we could go through the wanted
the help wanted list and I think we
could do a pretty good job of matching
opportunity with education
thank you for that thank you sir further
questions from that committee
yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you and as
to the dual enrollment what is being
done for the initiative to encourage
students to take advantage of those as
you said expanding into five stem
courses being offered through that
scholarship and what is done for high
schools to give those opportunities to
students so they know about them and
thanks for the question representative
McDonald director Doran can probably
elaborate but each of our campuses has a
running start coordinator working with
high schools in each of those areas we
do as much as we can to make visible
this opportunity the ability to expand
from two to five is still contingent on
funding but this is part of a larger
Effort New Hampshire as you probably
know Governor yesterday and his
inaugural address was remarking on New
Hampshire having the lowest poverty rate
in the country which is laudable but if
you look at K-12 population 20 22
percent of our students are eligible for
free and reduced lunch The Future Has
challenges for a lot of our students and
we recognize the importance of creating
opportunity Pathways that will be
affordable combination of what we can do
with dual enrollment programs and the
consequence of Representative Ford's
house bill 1530 which builds Pathways
between the community college system
University system is a long-term
strategy for helping to ensure that more
New Hampshire's young people have those
opportunities
thank you you're welcome
uh Mark uh we we've heard in the past
that 60 of the kids coming out of high
school going on to the community college
system required some kind of Remediation
in mathematics of which
50 of those never graduated now I
understand you don't have that type of
way of approaching that now that you're
trying to work with these students but
are you still seeing kids arrive that do
not have the mathematics understandings
that they really need to make it through
your programs uh yeah absolutely that's
the case and you can look at the annual
assessment results for 11th graders and
recognize that you're going to have a
group of students on the cusp of
graduating from high school who are
still not well prepared for college
level math
the revealing sentiment is to use
something called co-requisite rather
than remedial courses putting students
into college-level courses but with
sufficient support to encourage or to
increase the likelihood of success the
remedial courses have not had a good
track record for college math
so this just to follow up to that and
maybe it's better directed over to your
your friend there Beth but um
to determine if they're ready for a
college level mathematics course we used
to give the Next Generation
um
accuplacer and if there's a score of 60
or something you know are you giving not
necessarily that assessment but some
other assessment now to understand if
they are prepared so they don't end up
spending all this money and not getting
any return for it the approach is
described as multi multiple modes of
assessment it's placement testing it's
looking at the high school transcript to
see what the math pathway has been to
that point the students performance so
we try not to do a single high-stakes
measure of this score turns into this
placement but you know trying to help
students make good decisions for where
they are academically
thank you further questions
yes representative Ford
hello again good to see you sir thank
you for the acknowledgment of the bill
that we've worked together to get done
uh one of the questions that has
occurred to me as we look
at a lot of the data that's coming out
about uh people who are challenged or in
otherwise not given what's considered
Equitable opportunity
I was wondering if you had noticed also
that there's a group missing from there
and it may be a group which possibly is
a community colleges could uh could
address and speaking of those people who
are physically challenged the wheelchair
athletes to my knowledge there's no
wheelchair Athletics program in the
school systems in New Hampshire there is
one in an athletic group
but it's not there and I know that it's
very Broad in other areas other states
the college where I was president had a
varsity wheelchair basketball
it was that much of a commit but it
seems like they've been lost somewhere
in the equity and I was wondering if you
had any perceptions about how the
community colleges might address that
need
can I just ask a clarifying question to
you before for Mark handles that I
thought we passed Unified sports last
year
perhaps in Woodcock there are Unified
sports I'm not sure what the college are
at the high school level yeah at the
high school level I'm just talking today
at lunch I thought yesterday was
terrific yeah
good
um
um in competitive Sports some of our
campuses do offer that I can't speak
many detail in response to your question
so I apologize no it's not that it's
it's an idea that has not grown very
rapidly in New Hampshire and I thought
of it as one possibility for addressing
those students because they do very well
in their academics they have a very high
graduation rate and Career Success so
that that's what prompted my connection
was I'll say when you pose the question
my first thought actually turned to UNH
and Northeast passage which is a an
extraordinary organization within UNH
that does a great deal with adaptive
Recreation and competitive Sports to the
level of of international paralympians
an area if you're interested in
president Dean can connect you to that
thank you
yes represent Woodcock
um
Chancellor thank you for for being here
uh going through this with us every year
uh in terms of the I was going to
rephrase the old term of remedial
classes uh you I had a term I hadn't
been aware of but uh is there any uh
connection in the community college
system between I what you're identifying
as uh academic needs of students coming
from the typical K-12 system uh
getting that information back to these
are Pathway to get the information
packed to the curricular Folks at the
high schools that send you or to the doe
as we Guys these particular concepts are
missing with these particular core
courses for youngsters we now offer a
missing in terms of I guess is there
is there a way for us to find out or if
the schools particularly K-12 schools
what courses really need more before
they get to you is there any that
linkage back between a community college
system in the high school or doe I don't
I don't know thanks for the question I
don't know that there's currently a
reporting mechanism for that I can
recall from 17 years of work at UNH that
there was a standard report that
provided feedback to high schools on
performance for students in certain core
courses during the first year I'm not
aware that there's a similar report that
that we issue
foreign
conferences every year can back and
that program has been
running for three or four years now
so that gave us an opportunity to make
this one High School
thank you my colleague director Doran of
college access programs for the
community college system make a
Chancellor thank you Mr chair yeah the
math learning communities program
there's a chapter of law if you look in
the statutes on that uh about three
years ago is when we started we had 38
high schools participating in that
program and we were seeing great gains
there was a monies that Beth had gotten
Grant wise it was 200 000 I believe a
and what happened is we refuse as the
state to refund the program
and unfortunately then we're we're
losing the advance of the two courses
math foundations and the quantitative
math if they get below 65 on the
accuplacer rather than going from
Algebra 1 to Algebra 2 then they go into
the other right now which deals with
learning styles teaching styles and and
really does a wonderful job we were
seeing great success for two hundred
thousand dollars this house Let It Drop
and so that bill has been put forward
again this year in conjunction with the
community college system and we're
hoping to push this thing through so we
can address this issue of mathematics
and so we can adjust the issue of
getting that coordination you're looking
for between the high schools and the
community college system
hello thank you for taking my question I
was just looking through this
material here and the thing that struck
me is the ratio of female to male
students is very high I'm just looking
at 177 versus 23
um maybe that's one of the highest 65 to
34 and I'm just curious it just struck
me so I'm just curious as to what you
would attribute that to
um that's 77-23 is River Valley
Community College and it's particularly
attributable to the concentration of
Health Care related programs that they
deliver if you look across the colleges
there are different sets of programs and
certain programs tend to draw
differently from the population dental
dental hygiene program than HCI 98
female as an example nursing
disproportionately or I should say
significantly
favoring women automotive technology
welding more often than not men so it
really is a function of program mix and
the other piece that's unique to River
Valley
significantly larger share of older
students matriculating there rather than
students coming directly out of high
school and part of that is the not a
large number of high school graduates in
thank you very much
okay we're at pretty much at the end of
the higher education and do you have
anything else for us if I might yes and
took a moment to refresh my mind on
script
um on what is numbered as page seven
you'll see a graphic there and it is the
one that I would draw your attention to
because this has come up in previous
discussions we haven't completely froze
intuition but it's only increased five
dollars or two percent over the last
10 years
and as you'll see in that graph had we
allowed inflation not higher education
inflation which is typically twice as as
uh virulent as as consumer inflation but
if we had simply allowed inflation to
run its course that figure would be
about
278 dollars rather than 215 dollars
that's part of the effort to ensure
affordability we've been trying to hold
the line on on costs for students the
dual enrollment trying to find ways to
help students progress through and
complete college with less cost
in other states and particularly those
that surround us as a growing interest
in free community college and we're
we're going to see if we can't make a
serious run at that this year one of the
favorable opportunities if you will the
federal government has increased the
Pell Grant limit for next year
approaching sixty nine hundred dollars
not quite enough to cover tuition in a
lot of states that talk about free
Community College their tuition is
already low enough that Pell Grant
covers it it's a fairly simple thing to
do but we think we're close enough and
it's worth reaching we still think that
that puts our students under a lot of
pressure it doesn't really address the
needs of part-time students adult
students students who have exhausted
eight eligibility through enrollment and
other institutions but we think that
this issue to try and Achieve greater
affordability for our students and their
families is a critical part of our
mission on behalf of New Hampshire so
you will see and hear more about that as
we go through this legislative session
thank you very much that's very
interesting I'd like to hear more about
that
um any further questions for Mark
Rubinstein yes
is it okay to just make a comment as
I'm in Sullivan County and I just wanted
to say that River Valley Community
College is very well respected in the
community and I think I literally know
hundreds of people who wouldn't have
gone to college without the programs
there who are staying in New Hampshire
and gainfully employed it's pretty
impressive thank you and it's very
impressive and I hope nothing I said
cause you to think I felt otherwise
about one of our Seven Sisters River
Valley is also by the way the the heart
of our LPN program brought back at the
request of the state a couple of years
ago originally offered in uh
um Lebanon now available in
um
uh Laconia
Littleton it'll soon to be in Nashua and
Manchester it's it's serving as the hub
for being able to deliver programs
across the state with only one
institutional accreditation required
part of a model that we're evolving to
collaborate around programs to better
yeah great thank you very much
really appreciate your taking the time
to come and share these thoughts with us
and thank you information to the
committee for your interest thank you
thank you Shannon shank and thank you
Beth
Shannon have you been introduced to the
committee yet uh Tom have you been
introduced to
these are frequent flyers
Tom why don't you introduce yourself
foreign
thank you and Shannon why don't you do
the same you've been around here for
years I'm sorry
but
difference
both have been very helpful when we
tried to take courses and have them
transferred from one level to the other
level and we went through a lot of work
last year with representative Ford and
got that bill passed and
a great job I look forward to more of
okay on the docket we have the school
we have bear Christina and Becky Wilson
good afternoon chairman lad good
afternoon members of the committee to
the returning members of the committee
it's nice to see everybody again I hope
everybody's been well had a good holiday
season and to the new members of the
committee who have not had an
opportunity to meet just yet
um I look forward to working with you
and welcome to the best committee there
is in the House of Representatives my
name is bear Christine I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire school
boards association with news Becky
Wilson our director of governmental
relations I'm passing around a packet
with just some information about the
school boards Association who we are
what we do why we exist and some of the
positions that will be taking and I must
apologize my first introduction to you
and I did the cardinal sin of handing
out a document does anybody know the
problem with it it's it's not three-hole
um but anyway
um just to give um a brief background on
on the school boards Association and and
who we are and what we do we're a
private non-profit organization we have
about 161 school boards that pay dues to
the association and in return for those
dues we provide a variety of services
first and foremost our legal and policy
Services we have a staff attorney that
Fields legal inquiries from school board
members and school superintendents all
day on most matters of school board
governance right to no law budgeting
collective bargaining student discipline
staff discipline interpreting various
statutes interpreting Department of
Education rules so on and so forth
anything that can happen in a in a
school on any given day nhsba is able to
provide some resources and service and
assistance to school districts
the second primary service that nhsba
provides is our policy Services as some
of the newer members may know
um school boards are essentially policy
making bodies and there are a variety of
laws both state and federal that require
School boards have a particular policy
on in in a policy manual for example you
have to have a policy on bullying for
example you have to have a policy on
restraint and seclusion of students so
nhsba through our staff attorney drafts
sample policies and then we provide
those to local school districts to
tailor and amend and fit to their own
particular needs recognizing that the
policy needs in Manchester may be
different than the policy needs in state
Berlin or Colebrook for example
in addition to providing the sample
policies we do two policy updates per
year we do one we call it our fall
policy update it usually comes out we
usually distribute it around Labor Day
and and the policies in that policy
update always follow the legislative
session the session ends in May or June
we review the bills and what's become
law wait for the Governor's signature
over the summer and then we review all
the laws to see what Paul what bills
might have a policy impact it may not be
a policy that's required by law for
example but it may have a the law may
impact either an existing policy or may
require a new policy or a modification
to an existing policy so we do two
policy updates per year we work uh the
one in the fall and then we do another
sort of General update usually in the
spring then April or May sort of time
frame in addition to those policy
updates and drafting sample policies for
school boards to use we do do policy
reviews for school districts where are
these school board or the school
district will send us I still like them
when I did it I still did them all
um hard copy I like the manual so I
could write my own notes and then things
of that nature on them our staff
attorney now he's sort of got his own
system but a school district will send
us their policy manual and we will
review it we'll go through word forward
Page by Page line by line to make sure
that it's up to date to make sure that
it reflects current law to make sure
that they have all the sample policies
that are all the policies that are
required by law and then we'll write a
review and send that out and hopefully
give the board a school the school board
plan on how to implement the changes
that nhsba is recommending so that's
legal and policy the third primary
aspect of what nhsba does is what I'll
just call our training we do probably 15
to 20 webinars a year Becky was doing
one on a legislative preview actually at
one o'clock this afternoon and was April
and no noon I'm sorry at noon and was
able to get down here by one o'clock so
we do about 15 or 20 webinars every year
again mostly on matters that are within
the school board's purview collective
bargaining budgeting rights and law we
do do a new school board member
orientation webinar in April and May
following March elections and in
addition to the to the 15 or 20 webinars
that we do between my staff attorney and
I we will do anywhere between 40 and
maybe 60 or 70 individual trainings
every single year we're a school board
or the superintendent will call us and
we'll we'll go up or down or left or
right depending on where their district
is
um uh and uh and provide a training
sometimes it trolls and responsibilities
sometimes it's right to know law
sometimes it's collective bargaining
sometimes it's having an effective
meeting we get a lot of requests for
those so
um those are the primary the the primary
aspects relative to our training
um personally that's my favorite part of
the job I enjoy going out to the small
towns in New Hampshire and the little
elementary schools that I wouldn't
otherwise have an opportunity to visit
and actually see our members and
actually talk to our members it's easy
for me to say at my office and Concord
and think of think of maybe some good
ideas maybe some not so good ideas but
going out meeting our members where they
are is my person is my favorite aspect
of of the job in addition uh we do um
some other ancillary Services we do do
superintendent searches we do anywhere
between three and eight of those a year
I think we're currently engaged in about
four or five across the state I imagine
we may get a couple more this spring and
we do strategic planning for school
boards as well too at any given time
we've got two or three districts that
we're working with on engaging strategic
planning so I wanted to lay the
groundwork for the majority of what
nhsba does that that's the bulk of of
the services nhsba provides we do are we
are engaged in legislative advocacy as
you can tell Becky and I are both
wearing the orange badges we are
registered lobbyists we fill out the
reports we register every year and
lobbying the legislative with the
legislative work that nhsba does
accounts for probably less than 10
percent of of what we actually do we
spend a lot of hours down here tracking
a lot of bills obviously speaking with
the legislators going to helping um
draft bills from time to time helping
helping with amendments from time to
time
um but I I I don't want the new members
to think that all we do is come down
here and Lobby and advocate for either
more money or for this or against that
and the the legislative work is is a
fraction of of what we do our Prime
responsibility is providing the services
to school boards
um as a resource and as assistance to um
uh you know to those school boards I I
imagine at one point or another I have
been I don't know where all everybody is
from I know most of the the returning
members I know where your communities
chances are I've been to I've been to
your communities many times I've been to
Abrams at April last summer I've been to
Hudson a number of times representative
um uh represent cascad and I have worked
together many many times over the years
so that's certainly been to Manchester
as you know representative so
um you know we truly are Statewide
organization Torero tried to provide
those Services the assistance
um for the school districts that's what
we're trying to do relative to our
testimony though
um uh I will in here I'm sorry I didn't
get a chance to to number the pages
um but if you turn to the the second the
second page and I'm not going to go
through all these by any means it's
policies resolutions and statement of
beliefs manual the positions that nhsba
takes here at the legislature Are Holy
um uh uh a developed by our locals by
our school board members it's not myself
thinking it's a good idea it's not Ms
Wilson thinking this is a good idea or a
bad idea we have a delegate assembly
every year which is akin to a your town
meeting your school district meeting and
I'll remember submit proposed
resolutions
um and then we discussed them we debate
them and and we go through them and the
body whoever shows up at our delegate
assembly they vote on the positions that
nhsba takes I want to be clear about
that aspect as well too that it's our
members and and and in some cases your
your constituents that are determining
the the positions that the association
takes so you'll often hear us testified
when we do when especially in our
written testimony you know I will say
nhsba supports this bill because and
then I'll try and tie it back to a
specific resolution or nhsba opposes
this bill because and then try and tie
it back to a specific resolution so
we've got a basis as to why nhsba is
taking the positions that we take so the
the the the the leading documents after
the cover page are the nhsba resolutions
the existing resolutions and what we
call continuing resolutions
um they have to be adopted for three
consecutive years before they move into
our statement of beliefs manual that's a
in a side not necessarily important for
for this committee but also included
with this document just to sort of give
you a sense of who we are and what we do
we do do a legislative summary every
year I didn't print out and provide
copies for everybody because it's about
40 or 50 pages long but it's on our
website it's free access it's not
password protected or anything if you go
to
nhsba.org and you should be able to find
it under a documents tab if you can't by
all means email myself or email Ms
Wilson and we'll be able to get it to
you but I wanted to just sort of show
you that we do do a legislative summary
every year in the middle of the document
I did print off the cover page and sort
of the table of contents if you will so
you can get a flavor of what it looks
like but if you want a copy of that let
me know go to our website and and you
should be able to find it the other
aspect the other documents that are
included in here sort of the the last
maybe third or so is um the training
document that we use for our roles and
responsibilities training where we sort
of highlight the responsibilities of the
school board to highlight the
responsibilities of school
superintendents and administrators and
then
um you know sort of you know the best
practices if you will is sort of that
gray area that it's really not clear and
the relation working relationship
between school boards um superintendents
the administrative team so on and so
forth so
um I think my my emails on the on the
cover page as Wilson's emails on the
cover page we look forward to working uh
with you all if you have questions about
a bill if you have questions about a
particular law if you have questions
relative to public education or the
statutes of the Department of Education
rules that are not necessarily pertinent
to the work that you're doing here or to
a bill that's before this committee you
are free to reach out at any time we're
here to be we're here to be assistive to
this Committee in any way that we can be
whether it relates to life legislation
or whether or not it may relate to an
issue in your own in your own particular
community so um with that I I think that
sort of covers the who we are and what
we do and why we're here and give you a
little insight um as to who nhsba is and
the positions we'll be taking why we'll
be taking them and if there are any
questions from from from the committee
I'm certainly certainly happy to answer
them but thank you for the opportunity
chairman LED thank you very much are
there any questions for the school board
so yes representative Miler so so thank
you for being here thank you for taking
my query
just to be just to be clear your your
organization is rep represents elected
officials from local school boards
that come together on an annual basis
and establish the policy
for the organization of which then you
represent here uh when a bill comes up
Etc that is reflective of that elected
body not your personal opinion but those
from that elected body is that correct
thank you for the question
representative Miler just to clarify we
do not represent individuals
like we represent the board as an entity
so it's the board that's paying you know
dues to the association not you know an
individual School Board member
um but yes the positions at nhsba takes
are um derivative from what our local
school boards want they're either ones
who determine it's like I said it's like
an annual meeting each School Board
sends one voting delegate
um we send out the the proposed
resolutions weeks months ahead of time
their local school board that makes a
decision of whether or not to support
this proposal or not support this
proposal their delegate comes and they
they they carry the water for their
local school board if you will but the
positions that are are in our our
resolutions are our handbook if you are
statement of beliefs are are determined
by Our member school boards
further questions yes going down the
line represent Woodcock then we'll just
shoot down thank you Mr I just want to
apologize for coming late uh in the
presentation and thank you for the work
you've done the last four years you and
Becky I appreciate it thank you very
much representative
thank you Mr chairman
um
61 school boards and that's out of how
many possibilities thank you for the
question representative there are 176
school districts in the state
um of the 15 or so that are not members
most of those are either school
districts that don't operate a school we
have some of those it's a small town of
the mountains they've got maybe 30 kids
they tuition them over the mountain
because it doesn't make sense fiscally
to maintain a school and then the other
ones that are not members are again
primarily some K through two k-4 type of
type of school districts where very very
small student population in the school
board does not have
for lack of a better phrase a ton of
responsibility
thank you thank you
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair
um I believe I understand most of the
stuff I've read in here but there's one
thing that I'm not entirely clear on
when it comes to continuing resolutions
for 2022 item number seven on page two
NHS people advocate for legislative
action that ensures local school boards
comply with federal firearms laws and
policies
um I just I'm not actually sure what
that's refer but what exactly is
referencing um so I'm not aware of like
sort of
Authority school boards may have when it
comes to Firearms law sure certainly
thanks for the question representative
um indeed under under state law school
boards don't have any authority to
regulate firearms on school grounds
um
as a with respect to I'm just going to
use the phrase adults there's a federal
gun free school zones act that prohibits
students and pupils from having guns on
school grounds with some exceptions but
the federal law only applies to students
so the the I'd have to go back and check
my notes as to the rationale as to why
this was put together
um
but I think it was a statement
firearm laws and policies I'd have to go
back and check my notes represent I'll
try and follow up with you but just so
we're clear under state law right now
school boards cannot regulate the sale
possession use Etc firearms on school
grounds and nhsba by advises are members
of that despite me you advocate for them
to be able to is that is that what I'm
hearing I'm sorry but you were but you
would uh Lobby for them to be able to is
that what I'm we we do have a we do have
another resolution it's in our statement
of beliefs manual that nhsba supports
limiting firearms possession to only law
enforcement officers on school grounds
we do have a position on on that topic
as well too thank you yeah it says I
forget exactly where it is but it'll be
in the the preceding pages of that
are there further questions to the
I don't see any hands uh I want to thank
you very much uh the other day when I
was trying to write some legislation
dealing with weighted amounts for
various categories of IEPs
I contacted Barrett and then he referred
me to Becky who has got a background in
school special education directing and
what school district was that in uh most
recently in the Hopkinton school
district yeah but prior to I so for
people who don't know my prior work so
prior to coming to the school boards
Association I did serve as a district
administrator for 21 years here in the
state and I hold five Department of Ed
licenses can still so my role really is
to I'm not an attorney so my job is to
think about
operationalizing some of the policies
and things like that that you'll talk
about here in this committee and what
the implications are you know when the
kids get off the bus once you know more
or less yeah I think I should have
introduced I should have given that
background to Becky for the new board
members I'm an attorney by trade I was
staff attorney for the School Board
Association for about 12 or 13 years
before I moved into the executive
director role I don't know if they still
give you the the books the the law books
with the 1300 pages in there it's my
responsibility to know every one of
those pages
um and as Ms Wilson said she was
formerly special ed director
um District administrator for 20 years
has multiple certifications from the
department and she's the she's the
educator on the staff I know the law and
I know policy and board governance Becky
knows the curriculum instruction
assessment so on and so forth so well I
really appreciate it Becky and then you
contacted Jane Bergeron over here in the
administrators Association for special
ed and
it got the job done yeah and so they're
a good resource for getting information
are there further questions from the or
for the board no thank you very much
thank you look forward to working with
okay uh we had
see we started this at one does anybody
need a short break
we're going to take a five
in in education they always say get up
let the kids stretch okay I'm going to
let the kids stretch thank you for about
can you get up Oliver oh yeah he made a
handbook the sky hook
yeah
now I'm gonna have some water here first
foreign
the latter part of the uh orientation we
have set up for today right now Jerry
fruit is already at his C here ready to
roll for us are representing this New
Hampshire school administrators
Association welcome Jerry thank you
chairman Ladd appreciate the opportunity
Vice chair cordelli members of the
committee it's really a great
opportunity I will try to be
short-winded I know the weather is not
kind to us right now and you've been
here for a long day and you have a
packet of materials and in front of you
and I'll just briefly touch on what's
contained in that packet and
if you have insomnia and want to get to
sleep sometime soon you'll have that to
accompany you my name is Jerry Prue I'm
the associate executive director of the
New Hampshire school administrators
Association Kyle Ladd is our executive
director Carl is ill today he was
actually going to do the primary
presentation so you're stuck with the
wingman for this for this particular
opportunity this is my 48th year in
public education all in the state of New
Hampshire I am a resident one schooled
lived close to 70 years here public
education is a passion
I am privileged to have worked in a
number of school districts in this state
um doing some great work in some
wonderful communities
I am a husband of 48 years a dad a
Grampy of seven wonderful little beings
that challenge our energy level each
time we see them
um
so that's a little bit about me and now
nhsaa has been around since 1941. we are
an association composed of
superintendents assistant
superintendents business officials human
resource officials directors of
Technology directors of special
education and human resource
individuals
in the packet that you have our mission
and I apologize to the chair for not
having everything three hole punched I I
Derek gave me the you know here in
Barrett say I said oh look at that part
so I appreciate your Indulgence uh on
the left hand side of your packet you
have kind of a little bit about nhsaa
the our mission
um guiding principles as Champions for
Children we honor Champions for Children
each year
um as part of a an annual event the
state is divided into five regions and
each of those saus is part of a region
um and so we ask each of our regions to
select a champion for children we have
an event we invite the governors invited
and the commissioner of Education
provided to acknowledge the
accomplishments of local Champions for
Children and how we acknowledge a
Statewide winner and that Statewide
winner is presented with a 2500
scholarship check to put toward their
cause in their local community that they
are working with so that's a proud
tradition that we've had throughout the
course of our really our existence as an
organization
um
the second colorful
piece that you have is a brochure that
really summarizes
um most things about
nhsaa you have our executive board our
current officers and directors
um again the mission and The Guiding
principles but
it's
interesting because
um
this committee sees a lot of of me and a
lot of the legislative work that we do
but as Barrett stated with the school
boards Association really the
legislative component is a very small
piece of of our work
our primary focus of work is
professional development for systems
leaders and in looking at the
qualifications and the certification
requirements of superintendents and
business officials and special education
directors and such we develop a
professional development program
annually that meets the certification
needs of the individuals who sit in
those positions in your local school
districts and that's part of the mission
of our association is to provide high
quality professional development so
those folks can maintain their
certification
we are Clearing House of information our
five regions as I said meet um every
month and share great
strategies and local information
and really support one another we have
great coalitions with a number of other
organizations
we feel very much that every child in
the state
deserves the best that we can offer and
we're better together and so we work
really hard to try to share you know
educators are the best pirates in
America because we steal from one
another and we share and we are
shamelessly giving of information if
it's going to help kids in a neighboring
district and so that's part of what we
do as well with the with the regional
work curriculum instruction and
assessment we have a whole arm of our
organization that is meets regularly to
discuss issues of curriculum instruction
and assessment those again our regional
meetings and we have many curriculum
instruction and assessment directors
that are part of that group when this
committee has questions about curriculum
or instruction we're happy to provide
resources and information regarding that
we try to bring in our curriculum
experts as we can uh to you know they
work too so we try to get them into to
address any uh questions that folks may
have around curriculum or assessment
we work with communication we work with
career counseling and job placement for
new and aspiring superintendents we have
the granite state Leadership Academy
that we have uh our we're on our seventh
cohort of training tomorrow's systems
leaders we hope uh tomorrow's systems
leaders because we know that leadership
is an important component of keeping our
schools in our communities high
functioning and so we have uh about a
hundred uh who we have trained in the
past seven years we are on our seventh
cohort and the the whole program of the
Granite State Leadership Academy is
designed around the competencies to be a
superintendent of schools and you have
in this packet the whole outline our
Granite State Leadership Academy outline
and the competencies and the various
functions of really being certified as a
superintendent and again I'm not going
to take your time to go over those those
specific pieces because I think that's
just a lot
we do have a number of recognition
programs as I spoke to the Champions for
Children piece the superintendent of the
year which is a nationally run
um program so New Hampshire has uh
annually a superintendent of the Year
we're proud to announce it in 2023
um Reuben Duncan from the Jackie Ridge
District is our superintendent of the
year most recently
um Lisa Witt from the Monadnock District
was the 2022 superintendent of the year
we will on occasion bring those folks in
to talk with you about any particular
issues that you might want that level of
of discussion on
um
again we provide a great deal of
professional development and
opportunities to network share and build
capacity
another round of our organization we
have Consulting Services we work with
school districts and facility studies uh
demographic studies special education
studies
um
we've done maintenance and operation
studies but most recently we did some
work with the Hampstead School District
on a facility study but there are
districts who we've worked with probably
over the span of the association's time
we worked with over half of the
districts in we have a rich database of
demographic information birth data
housing data from all communities in the
state and it's provided some as a great
resource for
communities that are looking to do some
facility changes or study enrollment
Trends and that type of thing but we do
that as well
um
I'm going to come up for air for a
minute and just ask if there are any
questions
thank you are there any questions of the
superintendents Association
administrators Association
yes representative thank you uh thank
you Mr chair
um we had earlier this year
a study committee on teacher shortage
so my question I guess to you is what's
the average 10-year
of a superintendent
and and uh what is the field team look
like as far as availability of
individuals to fill superintendent's
positions across the state thank you for
the question representative Milo I
appreciate that question we did a study
internally uh from our association to to
look at the New Hampshire superintendent
because it it's different our New
Hampshire superintendents have a have a
tendency to stay a bit longer than the
national average
um and so that's been a good thing as
any of you who have been involved in the
change process knows that for Effective
change to take place it takes three to
five years for that process to happen in
any school district and so it's
difficult when you have top level
changes
um on a regular basis and our study
showed some interesting things and I
apologize for not having the knowledge
right at the top of my head we did
provide uh the committee that took up
this um issue with a copy of the report
uh and the information but uh typically
I'm going to say that
um there was 17 districts in the state
who have had the same superintendent
since 2016-17.
I want to say a little over a dozen and
I could be wrong so it's difficult uh
that I've had more than one
superintendent in five years
um and actually it might be 17
I think I have the numbers on it was 17
that have had more than one
superintendent in five years and 30.
actually had the same superintendent for
since 2017 the rest have had
um changes in one fashion or another
thank you follow it please yes uh yeah
what are some of the issues other than
covet what are some of the key issues
that superintendents are facing right
now as you've talked with your
colleagues
thank you for that question I think one
of the key issues that came back in our
survey was work-life balance
um the superintendents
day is a long one especially when you
have days like today
um it started last night uh typically
It's Not Unusual to find superintendents
on a on a and you have you have one in
the house that you might be able to get
some expert information out from at some
point but it's it's not atypical to find
superintendents uh you know on the phone
at five o'clock in the evening the night
before what is going to be a four
o'clock in the morning decision
um and so uh that that's but
from my personal standpoint as a
superintendent that was the worst part
of my job the weather related decisions
were the worst part of the job that's
awful I don't care what anybody says
it's awful because you can never make
the right decision
can never make the right decision
um that said because if you don't have
school there are kids who don't eat
and some people may say that's a
no-brainer not to have school because
it's not safe driving conditions but on
a Friday if you don't have school there
maybe kids are not going to eat until
Monday
so you have to think about those things
and that's but anyway that's that's
about a rabbit hole I'll get out
um but the the number one uh issue that
came out in our survey was the political
climate the political climate both at
the state level and the national level
and the local level and a lack of
respect and regard for the decisions for
the positions and for the work of the
hard work of teachers that have gone
unappreciated and under attack in many
places and the superintendents and the
administrators that are trying to
support those folks
um in a variety of ways and the rest of
the job hasn't changed the the emotional
and social needs of the professionals
who we work with and the
paraprofessionals and the staffs that we
work with have gained immensely and
superintendents of people too they have
families they they have a capacity and
yet they're the leaders who are expected
to provide the refueling of the tank
for all of these to be effective to be
effective they have to and they accept
that responsibility boldly and
and with pride but there's only so much
in the tank before you start here on
that you know tick tick tick and you
wonder if you're going to make it to the
next gas station or not uh and that's
been a lot and and thank you for the
question because that was really the
feedback that we got is that a lot of
our superintendents are on the tick tick
tick and the last the very last school
year
um 21-22 we average in the state about
19 or 20. believe it or not turnovers of
superintendents in a year and
um a year ago that number was 28.
and we're not talking about everyone
who's just at the retirement stage of
things it's unfortunate we're losing
some of the best brightest and um
potentially most energetic leaders in
our state because of of some of the
political conditions thank you
further questions
of Sam Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um referencing uh your handout here uh
New Hampshire school administrators
Association at the top on page two is
that the professional development one uh
representative this one right here if
you see it
okay okay
these glasses are for close stuff
I think it's in the back of your phone
yeah the next thing got it I see it yeah
thank you representative uh page two
item number one yes um
it says here uh as far as a professional
development 2022 best practice
conference on social emotional learning
uh so would it be fair to say your
organization is involved in bringing in
social emotional learning and if so do
you utilize the program
um developed by the collaborative for
academic social emotional learning
Castle
uh thank you for that question uh we
have worked with the Department of
Education to bring forward its social
emotional learning programs each as you
know uh we're living free and dying in
New Hampshire so there's a lot of local
decision making uh we value that our
association values that uh and
apparently from uh the governor's
inaugural address yesterday he values
that local decision making so it's we do
involve the castle program we don't
endorse any particular program what we
try to do representative is is provide a
conduit and and an opportunity for our
members to learn about a variety of
programs so that they can choose what's
best suited for their local community
not seeing any thank you very much
okay uh Jane I think you're up here
right New Hampshire special education
welcome and thank you for the help you
gave me here on the uh one bill I spoke
to earlier
thank you very much for the opportunity
uh to meet with all of you today my name
is Jane Bergeron bull you and I'm the
executive director for the New Hampshire
Association of special education
administrators and uh with me is
Jennifer dolliff Dr Dolph is the
director of student services for
Goffstown and Dunbarton correct New
Boston it used to be done Barton but
they they split away
um so we're happy to um have an
opportunity to talk with you briefly
today we won't take a lot of your time
we have provided you with a handout um
that gives you kind of an overview of
our organization as well as some facts
around special education we've also
included a bit of information about our
legislative priorities so just a little
bit about the association we're a
non-profit Professional Organization
supporting leaders of um in the field of
special EDU education from around the
state we have about 280 members
and those folks play a variety of
different roles the majority of them are
special ed administrators but we have
building coordinators we have out of
District coordinators preschool
coordinators so we have some school
psychologists speech language
Pathologists who might have a leadership
role within their educational
communities we also have a group of
individuals who are leaders in our
private special education schools that
are approved by the department of Ed so
we have a pretty diverse group of
professionals within our organization
um in terms of our priorities we kind of
have three big areas very similar to
that of the school administrators our
first big priority area is around
professional learning and similar to um
the school administrators we do a lot of
support with our members in terms of
leadership development keeping them
current in terms of policy and law as
well as keeping them up to date in the
most current
instructional and curriculum kinds of
issues that we face in terms of meeting
the needs of kids with exceptionalities
um the second big bin in terms of our
priorities is around communication and
Partnerships and really focusing on
developing Partnerships with the
Department of Ed with our advocacy
groups with the other professional
organizations ensuring that um they're
aware of the importance of meeting the
needs of the children and youth with
exceptionalities that are in their
school districts and then the third
priority area for us is advocacy and
legislation we're really following bills
that impact children and youth with
disabilities and their and their
families so we track and and really
watch those kinds of bills in terms of
that area
when we think about our legislative
priorities
um we track bills that are coming
forward
um and some and we try to really
prioritize and our first area is around
um high quality Educators
um as you heard
um teacher shortage is tremendous in the
field of special education as is with
special ed administrators we're seeing a
real critical shortage in those areas
and not a big pipeline of people going
into the field so any bills or
legislation related to promoting the
high quality uh pipeline of Educators
we're really focusing on that we're also
focusing on finance and funding as you
know that's a critical issue in the
field of special education so bills and
legislations connected to finance and
funding when it comes to special
education
we also focus on social and emotional
Wellness wellness and safety of students
especially those with exceptionalities
and ensuring that they have high quality
Mental Health Services and a real
coordinated set of care for those who
might have significant Health needs so
that's just kind of a snapshot of our
organization our priorities as an
organization and legislatively what our
legislative committee has identified as
priorities we've also put in your
handout some facts about special
education in New Hampshire that might be
helpful to you as you talk about bills
that are coming forward I'm going to ask
Jen to cover some of that information
with you
so I'm going to begin on page two where
um it says special education facts so
our work is really um driven by the
obligations of idea so as folks know
there's a lot of legal responsibilities
annually every state is um rated rated
by the federal government
um and they call that the state
performance plan so for the 2022 year I
just wanted to share you with you folks
some things that we're pretty proud
about we were ranked a number of New
Hampshire's one of 22 states that met
all the requirements of idea
so there were no areas of concern we
were number seven in the country as far
as graduating students with disabilities
number five as far as students who are
dropping out
um
not number five in a positive way
meaning we had a good no a very large
number of students graduating who have
IEPs
um number three as far as post-school
outcomes and enrollment and higher ed
and number eight
um students being being competitively
employed if you look to the right of the
page two you'll see that we've had a
steady increase in the number of
students with um IEPs in 2001 there are
about 14.6 percent of our population was
identified with an IEP in 2021 we're up
to 17.9 percent nearly 18 percent of the
entire population and I I'm sure that
covid played a role in that as well
um
if you look on the bottom right
um 79 of parents in New Hampshire with
this of students with disabilities
indicate that they're happy they've
viewed special ed is favorable
um and on the next page I'll talk a
little bit about finances uh in 2020
um there was a study done
um by a committee on school funding and
using a cost model predicting
methodology they discovered that the
average cost of a student with
disabilities Falls between thirty
thousand and forty five thousand per
student
and that districts with larger
percentages of disadvantaged students
English Learners and special ed students
perform worse on average in districts
with fewer of students who have fewer
needs so the complexities of a district
plays a role obviously in how students
perform and I won't read everything to
you as far as a survey that gets done
annually the department of Ed puts out a
survey annually that asks parents about
their experiences with special ed 80 or
more reported feeling they have good
communication being that they're
meaningfully included and that they feel
an equal member of the IEP team
if you get if you look at the federal
funds we get State funds obviously and
then we get federal funds so the federal
funds come as part of the idea Grant and
I don't know if you can see the chart
that I have in front of you
for fiscal year 22 the state received 53
million and that Federal flow through
money that actually went to districts
and leas was 45-9
a 20 increase was made in the amount of
money the state received in FY 23 so the
state receives 64 million which was a 10
10.8 million increase while the
district's only uh earned an additional
1 million so I you know we struggle with
what's sometimes you know whether in
some states the federal flow through
money goes to the districts
entirely so
um it's a moving Target for us and when
we try to budget it's hard to know um
you know what level of funding so we're
seeing increases overall in many cases a
a federal funding special ed Aid was
formerly called catastrophic Aid so
that's for students with really
exceptional needs so you can see back as
far as 1998 we were receiving about 39
million in funding through that for
fiscal year 21 we're down to 29 million
so as costs continue to rise we struggle
more and more in meeting the needs of
students and I think I point out we
pointed out here in the bottom right the
doe does race setting for private
schools and so typically those rates
were set pretty pretty strict for and
firm for many years about five years ago
this does started increasing the rates
at a five percent rate annually and that
compounds as you can imagine our most
dis our most expensive placement for one
student went from will go from 140 000
this year year 247 000 next year so
those are challenging costs to keep up
with when our budgets you know typically
don't go up five percent
um
just uh you know just some I think
that's all I have to present I think you
know the association is a non-profit
Professional Organization and I think
Jane mentioned what we're committed to
who are voice for equity and Excellence
for students with disabilities thank you
uh our uh represent Allison thank you Mr
chairman just a clarification on the uh
would be the third page of the fact
sheet under federal funds uh employee 23
where you talked about the state
received 64 million in school districts
received 47 million can you tell us
where the other 17 million went
no we can't tell you that we don't know
um that's the so the federal flow
through money goes to the Department of
Ed and then the department of Ed
distributes in many states the federal
flow through money goes all to districts
right there is a set aside states can
make but it's a minimal amount we don't
have the answers to that and we share
that in the hopes of sort of figuring
that out and
um so I don't have an answer for you
okay
thank you for the question and I think
we know some of the money
um The Bureau administrator shares
openly that that most of the Consultants
within the bureau are funded out of idea
monies they're not um they're not state
employees they're not paid by the state
so a good chunk of the money goes to
that they use some of the money for
professional learning
um and I believe they use some of the
money to pay rent for their Bureau space
within the department of Ed facility but
beyond that not quite sure that that
does definitely does not cover all of
the money I think even when they were in
the department of Ed um
in the last location they were paying
rent to that to that building with the
federal flow through money oh follow-up
yes uh would it be helpful for you to
know if we could get some accounting for
the 17 million that would that'd be
great thank you
for the questions yes representative
Cornell thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question you said there's an
increase in students being identified
with a disability is there any special
disability that is increasing or do you
notice anyone more than another
I don't go ahead Jane thank you for the
question we we have looked at some of
the information we're seeing a huge
number of increase in very young
children being identified with very
significant and unique complex
disabilities ranging from
autism to very unique medical issues
we're seeing an increase when you look
at the numbers in autism also
um so I think those are two areas and
Jen you probably can speak a little bit
more I think we're while you may not see
it in the data we're seeing a lot more
students experiencing mental health
issues that's gone up significantly
um and I you know some of that may be
due to learning loss it's hard to tease
out what's what when um students you
know we're out of school for a period
but overall the population has increased
uh I just want to make a comment uh in
talking to the superintendent of schools
in the town that I live in up in SAU 23
that Laurie Melanson I asked you the
question where is she seeing the
increases or the spikes in special
education
and of the 13 IEP categories she said
other health impaired is jumping on us
now I would assume then and perhaps you
might be able to help me out would that
be a result of the covet era and the
mental issues or the home life issues
and all that's associated with kids who
are coming into school yeah Ohi is for
other health impaired so that can many
different disabilities fall into that
attention deficit mental health issues
if a student doesn't rise to the level
of being identified emotionally
handicapped people you know teams will
use Ohi so that that makes sense I think
your your understanding
um it captures so many different areas
of need
um
whereas the other 13 areas of disability
are very defined yes thank you Valerie
now
yes represent McDonald thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking the
question how much of this increase can
be attributed to an increased ability to
identify and diagnose these disorders
whereas opposed to an increase in the
we thank you for the question I don't
have the answer to that
um
I I really don't know I think you know
practices regarding evaluation and
identification haven't changed
significantly I think there's
um there's been a lot that's gone on in
the last 10 years
um that has contributed I think to those
numbers
thank you and I would expand on that you
know there's there's real set criteria
for the types of evaluations that need
to be done in the and the way the
decisions are made so that hasn't
changed in fact we're we're actually
lacking in terms of school psychologists
we can't get them we can't get speech
pathologists
um so even getting evaluations done is
is a significant challenge
representative woodcock
thanks chairman good afternoon and
welcome ladies uh during generally
during covid when many of the youngsters
were at home I mean the school systems
are closed down permanently for
in-person contact uh how are special
services typically provided
no I can answer that yeah thank you for
the question
um we were fully staffed and worked
remotely with all of our students all of
the students with disabilities were
either included in the General Ed
setting meaning they were taking part in
the remote learning that was going on
with all students we also had our
therapists online providing therapies
and teachers providing direct
instruction when needed so it was a it
was a busy time
and I think folks did the best they
could do we brought students back in as
soon as we could we brought students
with disabilities back in first
um
so it was challenging but I think folks
you know worked very closely with
students and tried to keep in touch with
the Father the students that had
um PT or OT issues was a scene where
those uh therapists going to the home or
is it did that occur pretty much
throughout the state it occurred with
students we got a few students we did
that with because they were you know
they need was such
um for the for some students they just
uh the therapists would work with
parents online to have them you know
have the students doing certain
activities and so forth but on on
special Circ in special circumstances we
did permit um folks to go into the homes
and do things
thank you thank you Mr chair yes
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question
um over the years at town meeting a lot
of numbers have been floated uh about
what a percentage of federal obligation
is for special education costs versus
State ones and I know that a lot of
money has come through the pipelines in
the last couple of years and things are
are a little bit different but are is
the federal government meeting its
obligations its statutory obligations or
are we getting unfunded mandates passed
down tests
her doctor
the federal government has never really
met the obligation I think there's
discussion about improving on uh what
they're providing this coming fiscal
year but no I think it's um yeah it's
pretty well known that it's not benefit
funded fully okay thank you very much so
the figure used to be they promised us
40 percent
what is it 17 16 where are we now I
think it's it's somewhere around there
and it's ridiculous yeah what's
happening I have a question for you
though uh back in
2009 when I came this joint we had about
210 000 kids in school and roughly
around 29 30 000 kids identified with an
IEP
that is the case again today we have
about 30 000 kids
and about 164 161 and somewhere the
Thousand kids so obviously we're having
more percentage-wise they're in special
ed right now and my other concern is you
know I'd like to know that's just not a
trend resulting from just covet either
uh it was identified prior to that but
I'm also concerned Why are two-thirds of
the kids that have IEPs males
well to enter the first party or to
respond to your the first part of your
question
um
I I don't know why they're males I do
think that there's some research uh I
don't think that I don't even know if
it's two-thirds I'd have to double check
on that that's the figures which I saw
on the sheets that come out of doe so
the but the first part of this were you
talking about public school students
because we are we're responsible for the
public schools it went from 210 000
we're down about 100. we have identified
students that we care for in the private
schools and the charter schools as well
so um that might be why that number
hasn't changed so as the population of
the public school students decreases and
we continue to service students with
disabilities in all these locations
um that will stay the same and it's a
great question on the on the males and
we'll look into that
I've asked my daughter that she's a
speech pathologist for their C's and all
that and it seems to be at the younger
grades
there's more mail than there is female
is that result of Readiness I don't know
is that a result of some other issue I
don't know
but something that I observe and I could
never figure it out
we'll look into that yes representative
uh thank you Mr chair and just to kind
of follow up on on your question
um
so we don't we don't test everybody for
Cancer all the time because we're
constantly producing cancer cells and we
would have false positives all over the
place and we wind up giving people
chemotherapy you don't necessarily need
it so I guess my question is are we
casting a wide net doing any sort of
universal testing within within schools
on these kids
um that might be rounding up
sort of so wild cases yeah we don't test
we don't test all students and we only
test students when there's a referral
made so the referral has to come from a
physician a parent or a classroom
teacher
um
so I you know I don't think we're
testing I think we're testing by
obligation when we have to
um and not all of those referrals result
in identification there really is
criteria that students have to meet uh
to be eligible for special education
services thank you
I would just expand on that just to say
New Hampshire schools are mandated to
have multi-tiered systems of support in
hopes that that will reduce the number
of referrals being made to special
education and that we can meet the needs
of more students in in our tier one and
tier two before they get to a special ed
referral representative
now thank you Mr chairman since the
issue of federal funds have come up for
the edification of the new members of
the committee
um the Department of Education is
basically funded
Personnel in the department of education
is basically funded through what 84 85
80 plus 85 percent of federal funds yeah
so the so the department
is really
strapped frankly to provide services to
school districts because the the state
does not really fund those positions
they're funded through Federal projects
Etc so I just thought it would be
important for you to know that for the
money is coming from to fund those
positions in the department
yes representative Balboni thank you Mr
chair
um I have a question regarding how um
special education services are provided
at private institutions especially in
regard to the New Freedom accounts
great question
um so it depends on what's sort of the
students going to a private school that
the parents place them in it's parental
you know
um we provide we we offer Faith which
means we offer a full IEP in the General
Ed setting and if the parent doesn't
want that they are eligible to receive
some of the federal flow through funds
and so the special ed directors in each
district meet
um with the the directors of all of
these schools and talk about how they
want to spend that that money that is
allocated for those students for Charter
students placed in charter schools we're
fully responsible for all of the
programming from identification to IEP
writing to accommodations modifications
goals everything
um so it's it it differs a little bit
uh just a follow-up Please Mr chair
um so in the charter schools you provide
the services directly in the charter
schools there are personal if they are
yes we either send people in or we
contract with agencies or we we pay the
charter schools to provide the services
okay thank you there is a list of the
options available in statute they can
also send to the sending the the sending
school to provide the service there
yeah
represent Lucas
I was waiting for the last of her
questions
um and what do you do as far as kids who
um so that's considered again that's
parentally placed meaning that they
would be eligible
they really wouldn't be eligible
um
well they would be eligible if the
school that they're attending is a
non-profit but if it's not if it's a
for-profit school I don't believe the
doe allocates funding to that to those
so if they were in a
you know if they were in a a school in
in your district and it was a non-profit
they wouldn't be eligible to receive
further further questions
the lights have been flickering and I'm
wondering what's going to go on here
what's going to go off or where the
shingles are going to go
um
so uh right now we have Brian and you
have your crew Nea and aft have you
flipped the coin to see who goes first
one
well yeah do it by way of Zoom come on
up Brian
in the AFT if you wanna if you want to
do it separately you can or if you want
okay
[Music]
thank you um so I do realize thank you
for having us I do realize it's the end
of a long day
um we're the only thing keeping you as
an aft from going home so uh we will
make this short
um but again thank you for having us Mr
chair um my name is Megan Tuttle I'm the
president for Nea New Hampshire I'm a
veteran 8th grade social studies teacher
I could never seem to make it out of
eighth grade and I'm a mom of three boys
um here in Concord New Hampshire so any
New Hampshire represents and I do have a
handout but you know as a veteran
teacher I'm going to wait until after I
speak to hand it out
um so
it represents about 17 000 Educators
across the state of New Hampshire and I
say Educators because it includes
teachers but it also includes all the
families of ESP so the different ESP
families are para Educators tutors aides
support staff custodians secretaries
Food Service workers and bus drivers so
we don't just represent teachers so you
will hear us talk a lot about Educators
because as we know everybody that comes
in contact with a child in the school
really does have an impact and is
crucial to that child's learning so we
do speak a lot about Educators as
opposed to just teachers when it does
mean just teachers will say that or just
ESP we represent Educators that work in
all parts of New Hampshire so you know
from Southern New Hampshire up to
Northern New Hampshire eastern western
rural suburban Urban you know if we
represent a lot we have just over
230 locals that we represent and some of
those are in Cooperative districts as
well we provide collective bargaining to
them we provide representation anything
that the local needs we will help with
it
one big thing we do is provide
professional development to our members
and we have a few big conferences a year
one of them is a fall instructional
conference and it's been held in bow
with representative hall for the past
few years but we do hold them all over
the state that's our big conference with
about five to seven hundred members they
come in there's professional development
ranging on anything from content area to
collective bargaining to almost anything
you can think of is there if there's
something that a member wants a training
on we will find that training for that
member and for that District we have our
new teacher and aspiring educator
conference that's coming up in February
and so the new teachers are considered
the first to five years for us aspiring
educators are those students in colleges
and pre-service coming into the
profession and so we call them aspiring
Educators instead of college students
but they are in you know programs for
teaching or things like that we have our
ESP conference in April and so that's
specific just to ESP
we also have our summer Leadership
Conference which does do a little bit
more development on things like
collective bargaining grievances we are
a union so all that is part of what we
do
we also offer a lot of one day workshops
we say one day those could be things you
know an hour training we do different
trainings on things like True Colors is
one thing that we do it's a personality
training a personality trait training
we've done it with administrators and
with Educators in the building which is
always interesting to see them working
together and how you can work with
everybody that you're working with your
colleagues Etc
one other thing that I don't think a lot
of people know about Nea New Hampshire
um is that we found it over 20 years ago
what was known as the New Hampshire
foundation for teaching and learning and
that was founded for primarily Educators
to get assistance in you know things
they needed for the classroom in schools
and things like that over the years it's
morphed and a few years ago the name of
it was changed to the Scott mcgilvery
Children's Foundation Scott mcilvery if
you knew him was the president the
president just before me of Nea New
Hampshire he was also elected a senator
right after his election and when his
term was about to start he passed away
he believed in this Foundation this was
huge to him he was a teacher in
Manchester
um you know you know so the dean was
changed and what the foundation now does
is really goes to helping children and
so we have
um anybody that's you know in the
schools can go online they can apply for
money for kids we do different things
like getting
winter clothes because it can't afford
you know boots
um snow pants jackets gloves mittens we
provide clothes for summer for children
that can't afford it we provide money to
help nurses in different office staff
have kind of a closed closet so you know
clean underwear
um socks I mean these are things that
people don't want to talk about but
these are things that are happening in
school so we help with those things we
help provide some food so they can have
a pantry closet
glasses if they need them and they broke
theirs and they can't afford new ones
those are the normal requests we get we
also have some extreme cases there was a
case where we had a um 11 year old and
had two smaller siblings the mother was
in deemed in are unfit to parent the
father was in prison an aunt took in the
kids couldn't afford them so they were
sleeping on an air mattress all three of
them together
we know if your basic needs are not
being met you cannot go to school and
get you know you can't learn so the your
mattress popped so now the kids are
sleeping on a hard floor
so one of their teachers did reach out
to us and asked if we would just get a
new air mattress so the board that we
have in Nea New Hampshire is I'm on the
board for it and they have their own
board now but what we did was we ended
up getting two sets of bunk beds you
know mattresses blankets stuffies there
was a four-year-old and a six-year-old
were the ages of the siblings anything
they needed that's a bit of an extreme
case on what we do in terms of the money
that we spend but those are the things
that if children need them and the
educators are seeing that that need is
there they go on they fill out the
application and usually within 24 to 48
hours they have something back we've
helped out with driver's ed for kids
that you know want to be driving and
need to take the class in order to work
to help support the family but can't
afford it so it's a wide range of things
that we do so that's actually something
that Nea New Hampshire is very involved
in that I don't know that a lot of
people know about and so we wanted you
to know that
different resources we can provide to
the committee we can help with research
we have you know some amazing research
we can do and I know Brian I'm sorry I
forgot to introduce Brian
um
um we have some research that you know
we've given to various committees in the
legislature over the years just recently
um we have National Nea policy papers
that we can get and you know we can
survey our members very easily on
different issues and bills that are
coming before this committee and other
committees so let me backtrack for a
moment and I apologize this is Brian
Hawkins he is our government relations
director for Anya New Hampshire and it's
usually one of the two of us that you're
going to see a lot of over the next
coming months um so it'll be both of us
here um I apologize
so some of our priorities for the
upcoming year addressing school funding
I know this is not a new thing for
anybody to hear from us we want to you
know ensure each child has access to the
education they deserve and that includes
all aspects of education so mental
health you know funding resources
everything that goes into education
um looking at the current Workforce
competitive pay
benefits supported environments to
attract and just retain Educators in New
Hampshire we have some amazing colleges
here in New Hampshire for education and
there are students coming out are
leaving to go to other states why we
want to keep them here in New Hampshire
and so we're looking at that but not
just the current Educators that we have
but also prioritize the incoming
Workforce so that pipeline coming from
the high school into the colleges and
then into the profession working with
programs like Educators rising in the
high school and future Educators Academy
in the high school those are the kids
that are going to be getting credits to
go into
the teaching colleges the education
colleges and then into the education
profession so looking at that pipeline
it's great to retain teachers that we
have and we need to and we need to
attract them but we need to also be
looking at the pipeline coming in and
that's where the pre-service comes in
starting really in the high schools
um you know ensuring high standards for
our public schools in all areas and the
last one really is addressing the
challenges that my members are facing
and they're facing a lot of challenges
there's you know hustle work
environments unfortunately there's
assaults on Educators from children in
2020 there was bipartisan legislation
that was passed and it addressed safety
plans it adjusts reporting in schools we
need to continue to work on this this
hasn't stopped when we came back from
the buildings being shut down education
wasn't shut down but the buildings were
shut down this didn't end I had a board
member of mine two weeks ago maybe three
weeks ago
um
she called to say that she was hit with
a metal clipboard that one of her fourth
graders threw at her and she ended up in
Urgent Care so I mean these are real
things that are happening in schools we
know that nurses were buying before
covid face Shields to protect themselves
from kids spitting on them we've had
biting we've had pencils thrown I mean
there's a lot that's been going on it
hasn't stopped so even though the
legislation was passed which is a great
first step we need to continue working
on this to make sure that these things
aren't happening
and the last challenge I just want to
talk about real quick is the increased
workload because the educator shortage
and I know Brian has a handout that
we're going to give you um on some
research from Nea but this is real we
have teachers that are giving up prep
time
to go sub and other teachers classrooms
because there are there is a shortage of
Subs there are no subs to be found
unfortunately bus drivers as well I mean
it's not just one thing
um and you know they are getting paid to
do this sometimes it ranges from 25 to
60 dollars per class but at the same
time they're giving up their prep time
in order to do this because the kids
need a teacher in the classroom
um sometimes that doesn't happen and as
I said I have three children three boys
they all go to public schools in Concord
we want my oldest is a sophomore at
Concord High School he called me last
week to ask if he could be dismissed
because he was in Commons B for the
entire block because there was no
teacher so he was literally just sitting
there for you know hour an hour and 20
minutes there was no teacher they didn't
have a sub
um so these are real things that are
happening these aren't things that were
you know envisioning or hearing about I
mean I'm hearing about them because one
as my son's telling me but you know I
know that it's happening for members Etc
um the only other additional
um topic I wanted to bring up is
you know it definitely is best
for the Educators to be here in person
to tell you their stories and ideally
that's what we would like to happen
um unfortunately because of the way
committee's work and the legislature
works and the way schools work they
usually can't be here so you are going
to see Brian and I speaking on their
behalf now I do have members who are
amazing at writing and calling and I'm
sure you're going to be hearing from a
lot of them this year both good and bad
you're just going to hear from them but
they would like to be here and I want
you to know that it's not that they
don't want to be here to tell you their
stories they just can't always be out of
school to do it because they are in
school doing their jobs which is what we
want them to do that's what they do best
and so we want them there
um so again you know we'll be here on
their on their benefit but you know if
you could just remember
they do want to be here
but they are doing what they should be
doing which is working with children so
I don't know if Brian wants to add
anything
I'll just add by way of introduction Mr
chairman it's uh good to see you again
and for all the returning members uh
looking forward to uh working with you
being before your committee again again
Brian Hawkins I live here in Concord I
work for Nea New Hampshire and only any
any New Hampshire so I don't I'm not a
lobbyist with other that has other
clients
um this is uh important to me because I
have two uh two kids a three-year-old
and a seven-year-old my seven-year-old's
in second grade and so ensuring that we
have a a robust uh public education for
all students in the state is is also
personal to me so again looking forward
to working with you all uh our leave
behind in addition to the information
that Megan talked about will also be a
document we share that our National
Association did on uh
reasons and and solutions to the
educator Workforce shortage uh shared
that with representative Ladd and
representative Ford and representative
Miler who are all on the uh teacher
shortage committee that had been meeting
and I believe will continue to meet
throughout the year
um and we'll and we are working with uh
legislators especially uh in in the in
the Senate and the house on on
legislation to hopefully uh address some
of these issues so
um thank you very much
thank you very much and I do have a
question for you or maybe a request for
some information
um when I look at a community like
Lebanon or Hanover
um I'm seeing
um
fewer vacancies
then I I am in communities north of that
I'm not talking about Lyme or or if I'm
talking about Haverhill or some of the
other communities where there's there's
a certain poverty level or there's a
certain ability you know when I have the
superintendent of school saying Jeepers
I'm gonna have to ask for a five percent
increase in order to keep these teachers
here employed and you have a community
that's not supportive of that or you
have a community it just doesn't have
the ability to you know raise that type
of dollar
have you done any kind of survey work to
find out is it is some are some of these
vacancies
a reflective of the communities I just
talked about like the havers of the
world or those which have you know other
issues going on or or is there a similar
issue in communities like Hanover or
Lebanon where you know they have pretty
decent schools and and and and not as
much vacancy
um is there anything there that we
should know about or that you can find
for us
sir yeah
um so no that's a great question thank
you for asking
um I can tell you that I did ask my
board my executive board some challenges
they were facing and what was one of the
biggest ones and one of them did right
back that um and he works in Rye they
raised the compensation they're still
missing about 50 of the pair is 20 in
custodians they're using Pairs and
parents to run the cafeteria so they
said this is in the number three and two
Community income tax to tax ratio New
Hampshire
um if you know Bedford New Castle and
Rye if two of the wealthiest districts
in our state still can't get people it's
not necessarily money okay
um so let's start again that's part of
the answer I that's part of it but
yeah and just to add to that um and and
we talked about some uh National
statistics during the the shortage
committee uh work but we are getting
ready to do some more in-depth serving
of our own local membership
um with uh those types of uh inquiries
and so we'll be happy to share that with
you and we had a fantastic art teacher
now working in Hanover
we couldn't keep her yeah
further questions from the committee
yes first from Woodcock thank you Mr
chairman good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen thank you thank you for coming
um has your group uh have any way to
solicit from the school board schools
themselves on about the current number
of unfilled teaching positions where you
have a ballpark number on that as we
no okay no you can
uh we have we the one bro no yeah uh we
we have uh I know that the uh doe has
put out a survey around this although
um one of the challenges and I think
there are some legislation that's going
to partly uh address this is there's a
we have a major data collection problem
in the state
um and that stems from a lot of reports
being asked of school districts but also
representative Myler referenced it
earlier the department is very strapped
um in a previous role uh uh when I
worked in the state employees
Association uh back during the recession
a lot of the funding
uh in order to for good reasons in order
to save positions save people's jobs you
know those positions that could get
switched over to federal funds were
switched over and there really hasn't
been a recovery from that
um and so uh uh I think that's uh an
important role that we need to to
support the department with
um and to so that they can better assist
school districts in making sure that we
have the data I think the the shortage
uh survey that I know uh uh director
Appleby put out and shared with the
shortage committee uh during uh when
they were meeting you know they were
only getting a fraction of of responses
and in terms of what what positions were
uh where shortages and I think I think
with through multiple passes 20 at that
time Brian now it's up to about 40
percent return from the school district
still shallow exactly and and and that's
all and that's only one data point not
just you know that's the shortage point
but
you know there are scores of other
issues Megan was referring to uh
incidences of uh you know assaults in
schools that's another one that uh you
know legislation was passed
we're still not seeing the kind of data
that's going to help you all make
informed decisions on what on on their
you know scarce resources that we have
this at the state level so uh I think
it's something we've got to work on
um but we we do talk to uh the other
associations on on this I know there are
some uh who have the the administrators
I think uh and Jerry might be able to
follow up with you on this I know they
put out a survey I think to their own
I guess I want you to find there's no
number we have no current number either
through the shortage committee or
through the Nea or the AFT about how
many vacancies teaching vacancies still
exist today in our schools in mid-year
director Appleby does have information
uh the number of teaching renewals on
certificate on certificates has
increased significantly this year than
in previous years
that was announced to the the committee
um when we started out there are 800
vacancies in the state in
paraprofessionals that was really the
sore point then in specific teaching
areas it was mathematics The Sciences
and special education
Mr chair I'm not asking for the cause is
there a number somewhere about how many
how many schools how many teaching slots
in our Public Schools yes that is
available they're still empty halfway
through the year that's that's my
question if the information was provided
us at the front side of the teacher
committee now I haven't asked Steve in
the last several weeks okay but I know
he's constantly getting information in
fact the surveys are slowly coming in
from the administrators as far as where
we are on all this okay but there again
you've got to remember these
administrators are piled with all this
other requests coming in it took us a
long time just to get the Emergency
Management operation plans in
thank you yeah if I could just add one
thing to hopefully try and answer some
of that if that's okay
um we could do a survey with our uniserv
directors and you know it wouldn't be
complete because we don't represent all
the districts in New Hampshire aft you
know represent so they could probably do
the same thing it could give a ballpark
I mean we could definitely talk to the
uniser of directors
um this week and or the upcoming week
and have them check in with the locals
I just it was January we're talking
January and we hear schools still have
classrooms that are not I'm not always
certified teacher I thought I was
someone that's competent in the subject
area in there not just the warm white
today something different tomorrow say
we thought it was a sub and I think it's
it's a number that needs to be known we
only have six months or less left in the
year and we're talking about we can't
figure out how many vacants do we have
the state of New Hampshire
I mean over there
thank you thank you okay
uh I know the question was asked is
Steve coming in on the 17th for the next
round here
um I don't think he's on the docket but
uh we can get that information he's been
very Cooperative in working with us uh
he's been at every one of those teacher
meetings which we've had shortage
meetings
um
I'm guessing I'm just I was just trying
to get a figure someone didn't have the
answer well I think we may have the
figure we've talked with the
superintendent in Manchester we've
brought people in from the southern part
of the state
um things are getting better uh however
I don't have the specific numbers
offhand of course it's not my job either
but we can get it we can get that
information and we'll we'll make contact
this committee will make contact with
doe with director Appleby to see to try
and get resolution to what you're asking
representative
further questions
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um regarding the
um the assaults that went on teachers
which are which is certainly a horrible
thing I have my own experience there
where a student of mine uh was
intercepted by security after having
applauded to stab me during my first
week
um so we know these are terrible things
and they really do happen
um uh through my research I've become
aware of a number of common sort of
diversionary Behavioral programs that
would tend to keep
troubled students students perhaps with
dangerous proclivities in the classroom
despite uh knowledge that they that they
do have these problems I I could add to
this list the names of a number of mass
shooters that have happened over the
last decade
um would you advocate for rolling back
some of these programs that do tended to
keep more more dangerous students in the
classroom
it's a tough one I mean it's a tough
yeah I mean I I could not answer that as
just a blanket yesterday you need to be
asking questions to them they're they're
here presenting to us we can ask for
information yes but we can't be asking
one p one piece I will I I we reference
that piece of a piece of legislation
that was passed in 2018 came out of a
study committee uh 2000 yes 2018 2019
um one one of the uh requirements of
that through the uh through the
Department of Labor and the work workers
uh comp statute was to uh make you know
safe those kinds of safety plans
required plans and those are those are
those are ones that management and labor
have to uh come together on and so that
that was one uh attempt to try and uh
maybe not necessarily from the
standpoint that you're talking about but
have plans around
um agree upon plans that everybody is on
the same page about knows how to handle
some of those situations so that both
the you know the student and the um and
the staff are are as safe as possible
yep
further questions not seeing thank you
welcome
let's see and yes I do realize I am the
enviable position of being the last
just looking around the the speaker so I
can see all the faces uh my name is Deb
house I'm the president of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire and
it is good to be back here in the
education committee room thank you for
inviting me chair lad and great to see
so many faces have recognize and
helping to get to know some of the new
ones
um a lot of what I have to say will
mirror what president Tuttle was saying
about trying not to be too repetitive
because I am aware of the time and and
the lateness of the day
um but anyway
um my state Federation is comprised of
29 local unions across the state most of
them are education unions we do have a
couple of other small locals we've got
approximately 4 000 members across the
state mainly in pre-k through 12 Public
Schools we also now have
the University
lecturers University faculty at UNH and
Plymouth State University as part of our
state Federation we have Fringe faculty
Federation and a couple of small groups
that are Town employees and city
employees I'm just going to be talking
about our education groups our members
are basically everyone you would
encounter in a public school except for
the administrator so that is Teachers
para Educators school counselors social
workers the whole team that are there to
support and interact with children on a
day-to-day basis in a public school
um
nurses included and the tender track
faculty the lecturers at UNH and
Plymouth state
and most of our members do reside in New
Hampshire there are some that live in
Mass but most of them do live here in
New Hampshire we of course are in this
because
we believe in public education believe
in engaging young minds helping them
learn helping them you know become
better
Learners uh better people shaping the
future we strongly believe that that is
a calling that is worth doing that is
why we are educators
we work with the locally adopted
curriculum and materials that the local
school boards approve
so curriculum is not something that the
union decides on it's not something
individual teachers or para Educators
decide on that is a local school board
decision
we just carry it out
um we communicate regularly with parents
about students on their academic process
progress and their behavioral
progress or
incidents
um
we know that students make the best
progress when teachers and School staff
can work as a team with parents and
families caregivers of whatever kind the
students have they're grown-ups at home
um
many of our members also volunteer their
time
outside of school after school to run
clubs uh for the kids because they know
that having those different activities
like the drama club or the LEGO League
or Destination Imagination is what
lights that kids fire what keeps them
going what keeps them motivated to come
into school and to maybe do the hard
work and sit through the math lesson
that isn't so exciting if they can come
to LEGO League afterwards or you know
read that novel that maybe they're not
too excited about if they're there to be
in the school play
or running track it just keeps them
going for
um you know the the science lesson that
maybe isn't the thing that's the most
exciting to them today
so we do all those things we also are
involved in our communities
um
three of our locals this year this fall
participated in aft's Reading opens the
world we gave away over 7 000 books so
that kids could have books at home
you know take home brand new books uh
that they could be excited about to be
reading at home
we also have locals that participated in
Toys for Tots Drive in uh packing
backpacks for kids to have needed school
supplies to go back to school and Adopt
A Highway programs we are part of our
communities
our priorities
we want to make sure our public schools
have everything they need so our members
could do their jobs well to support
their students learning
that's really as simple as that we know
we're in a teacher shortage especially
with special education math and science
and welcome back to that question that
representative Woodcock asks
um
I know there's that number out there
about teacher certifications being
renewed
and that that number has gone up but I
also know that that is not necessarily
the same as the number of teachers that
are actually actively employed because
teachers who have
retired and left day-to-day teaching
will hold on to their certification and
even renew it so they can come back and
some I have
um
two colleagues I worked with who retired
in the past two years one for health
reasons and another because she just
couldn't stand the stress anymore but
kept their certification up so that they
could continue to sub and when they
subbed since they have you know spent
years being trained as teachers they
want to get paid as a certified teacher
instead of just as a warm body sub
um but we know there's a shortage out
there and that shortage does need to be
dealt with
we need to keep the highly trained
qualified people that we have on the job
by showing them respect
by paying them adequately and by making
sure that the class loads and caseloads
are manageable we can't keep burning out
in particular our special Educators I
was just hearing yesterday about the
school that I won't say anything sorry I
was just here yesterday about special
education caseloads and some schools are
getting so high that we risk burning out
these people because of the shortage
we're putting more and more students on
their caseloads and if you don't have
any time for your own family
and you're trying to meet all the
paperwork needs and educational needs
and legal needs of these students and
you have all that responsibility on you
and you you cannot keep putting your own
family last
month after month year after year
driving good people away and it's the
we also do have shortages of math and
science teachers and we've got to find
a reasonable answer
before all of our students lose out
but we can't do it by lowering standards
of who we hire because that's not fair
to the students either and it's not fair
to the people who are working in the
field we need people who can do the job
we support efforts to make sure that
every student has the opportunity for a
good healthy meals at school
because hungry students don't learn very
well
we support efforts to make sure that
every school has adequate resources to
make sure that these students have all
the materials and Personnel they need to
get great education and we also support
adequate funding for the University
system so that families in New Hampshire
can send their students to school at a
New Hampshire
Public University
and keep their students here for the
next generation
hopefully you know building the
workforce
so those are our priorities and with
that
um I do not have a handout because I
will be sending this to you
electronically I'm trying to be a little
more ecological here
are there any questions from the
committee
yes representative leckers yep
you were talking about the workload on
the um particularly the special ed
teachers and Paras and whoever
um and I know 30 years ago I was blown
away by the amount of paperwork that
needed to be done is that has that
gotten any better or worse or what is
that like these days
it has gotten more complex
even even though it is done on computer
there are so many different forms you
have to fill out and legal requirements
that
would seem to be duplicative
but you still have to fill out this form
and that form and
within certain timelines so there's a
fair amount of stress there and in many
districts you have people who are
particularly Elementary level are both
case managing and teaching
so you're not just with the students
worrying about okay how do I help them
grasp this concept but you also have to
make sure you're getting all your
meetings in in the right amount of time
contacting the parents and arranging all
the meetings and getting all the
paperwork signed off and returned it so
you're doing
two or three people's jobs
and dealing with a student who because
they have learning differences aren't
necessarily going to get the first way
you present it so you're asking someone
to do
I'd say a very difficult job but you
know it's not really even just one job
with two or three very difficult jobs
which is why you're seeing so much
burnout
it's it's very sad because these
children need
the dedicated professionals who have the
passion to work with them
and to burn such people out on meeting
paperwork demand is it's a crying shame
thank you
follow up
I don't know if I have anything else to
say about it
no I just wondered
do you have any suggestions
[Laughter]
can you pass them on one suggestion
might be to to try and split the case
management from the actual teaching
portion of it so that you could have
someone focusing strictly on the
students needs and someone else focusing
on kind of the legal and paperwork
aspect of it
that
and so as someone who came out of
working with kit I was one of those tier
two people who who tried to work with
the kids so they wouldn't you know end
up in special ed so try and help them
before they they kind of identified that
would be an ideal thing because that's
kind of a great Niche to be in you know
working with the kids and seeing how
their minds work and and finding that
thing that Sparks the learning that aha
are there any other questions from the
committee
you cannot see it thank you very much
thank you
and I have to practice my handwriting
for you
yeah Carson Carson I I do have good
cursive but it gets Rusty between the
zaynor Blazer method where our Palmer
was another method yeah so thank you
very much everybody Hal you hung in
and everybody strives safely home it
looks like well it looks like it stops
no one
I I have uh contact uh information
sheets for everybody if you'd like to
um okay
okay
thank you very much everybody have a